people you know what time it is
let us know if we are live
are we live the only i wasn't even told
i was told by ripper
that's right
we're here
everyone's
excited it's gonna be a great show i'm
just plugging plugging the stream on
twitter right now yes
i will do the same
don't have my phone all right
everyone why are you guys getting quiet
is it because i'm not talking you guys
always wait for me to talk jesus christ
everybody
hey everyone all right i'll do all the
talking to god
i said i'm plugging the stream right
all right guys oh we got people coming
in what's up guys pouring in now wow
this really did jump
so with warren here
um
is it public knowledge where you stay
when you're here now yeah yeah uh maybe
i don't know sure he sleeps in our bed
yeah he sleeps in uh greg and olivia's
bed
right now between
uh warren is uh he stays in our back
house now and but the entire time every
time when warren's here what's up
can we not mention it
yeah yeah but every time warren's here
we don't actually do anything together
we really don't do anything i don't
actually like greg i mean no no no yeah
i'm just taking advantage of him max
mayfield but i was like you and john
switch seats
i know don't ask that i'm trying to plug
this guy i just put this on twitter and
then i can give my undivided attention
to this stream just make sure we can all
be warned can you do me a favor elias
lundqvist can you shout out some people
who are in the chat who are specifically
siphoning
uh citing you in the chat
it is heavy spoilers two seven you're
not really 27 mil
you guys have no idea how big this
monitor is
what is
[Laughter]
your name was all over the place pull
your mic closer to your mouth my darling
hi guys how's it going we go there you
go it's all right this is after play
this is a real reject stream well it's
always pure chaos i hope you realize
that yes oh hello too you know the thing
about chaos
it's fair it's fair
rob
what is going on laser sniper what is up
ld what's 3x woof woof what's that from
andrea what is up hey josh one night
what i'm doing what you told me we got
bucky
you know you know joe who's always
talking to us on twitter he's the one
who's our our moderator yes well we talk
and we talked about that before too
because he was just messaging me we
don't really don't go live at this hour
but you know i figured why not we're
talking all right so guys here's what
we're going to do today now that i'm all
focused up here to talk to you
where that was the stream we wanted to
talk about uh you guys are going to
control this chat you guys are going to
tell us what we're going to talk about
today we figured there's some we got d23
coming up in just a couple of weeks
there's all kinds of rumors over here
warren is constantly doing rumors and uh
all kinds of things that it might be
coming out of marvel and breaking stuff
down he's one of our marvel experts that
we also know so i was like warren you
gotta really help us out with this
stream today and you gotta help us
figure out like what upcoming characters
might be and which ones are the ones to
be most excited that people might be the
most excited to talk about today yeah
how does it sound that sounds awesome
don't worry we'll get past the
formalities what i do all the time yeah
exactly
so you guys are gonna tell us in the
chat right now but thank you to everyone
who's been here
what is going on everybody hello the
star wars nerd what's up
john jeffrey what's up dude john cena's
in the chat will john cena join the mcu
i'm sure he would love to join the mcu
i
just kind of think
i don't know if you're kevin feige
and like someone who's a major character
in the dc universe
do you want such a major character to
come over into the marvel universe like
would they actually have henry cavill
cavill yeah come to the marvel universe
you think i seem so iconic as superman i
think if he's not gonna be um superman
anymore if he's not gonna be superman i
think it'd be awesome to have here isn't
that the thing that people are always
saying that like uh he might be captain
burton
yeah i mean there's just a ton of fan
art out there of him as captain britain
and he looks really dang good he looks
like captain britain i think there was a
new rumor recently though that he's
playing
like hyperion or something really
something like that who's the hyperion
do it
do the thing break it down
break it down we're going to watch the
videos live glad i came on the show well
sidestepping from my period i actually
want him to be sentry
but people are saying that
pivoted there
we can talk about hyperinflation i just
think it'd be a better century but what
i was going to say about that is people
think that's just like
still superman
so it's like oh that's a fair point
because i think that's i think that's
the latest thing
i can't remember if it was hyperion or
century
the rumor that he's coming in as one of
those two characters but i've seen a lot
of
he's too close to superman since you're
too close to superman so he's
essentially
just playing superman still
sure
i would actually like captain britain
and i would like that whole side of like
because you know you have the captain
britain core with the multiverse how
they protect you know the multiverse and
stuff like that that fits perfectly in
with everything that we're doing right
now
so that makes the most sense to me
but i've also seen the fan art so i'm a
little biased because he looks really
great as captain britain so
i mean fan art can be deceiving that was
the thing about john krasinski in
fantastic fours he looked like the fan
art he actually really yeah i like the
fans of the fan are coming to live so
they do the same thing with henry cavill
that would be pretty awesome well and
you know the studios look at this stuff
they actually see it that's how uh
rosario dawson was cast as ahsoka
oh really oh yeah you didn't know that
fan art well why don't we just put
ourselves in fan art let's i'm wolverine
can you
john
john dude john's the expert
a moment of silence for our
666 con concurrent viewers mephisto
smiles upon
comes for us oh really quick guys
uh john discovered some sound effects
john do you want to which if when
someone gives a super chat what's this
button
there's only one sound for a super chat
horn that's that one for the super chat
that's right if someone gives a stream
labs
i'm just going to push a random button
it's going to be a bird chirp oh that's
what it is today
it's a solid bircher so i hear grace
randolph was live too and um and new
rock stars is going to be live in a
little bit too
[Music]
if you guys can when new rock stars goes
live if you can go over to them and be
like i just wanted to pop in here to say
i'm gonna be watching the real rejects
that would be awesome especially if
koi's live there yes i think coy might
be there and if koi's there be like coy
you're a traitor
you should be with the real rejects i
want you guys to really just hammer it
in to go ahead and kill the [ __ ] out of
it
it's okay if you can't donate don't
worry about it we were just we're just
let's go only like tab don't don't like
leave this window pull up another tab
though yeah yeah we don't want to lose
the viewers you know what i mean but we
gotta do it
i'm so sorry for your bankruptcy jedi
dick sensei um let's see here hello
henry cavill's cyclops a lot
uh esposito
okay giancarlo esposito a better magneto
or professor x justin rodgers wants to
know professor x for sure you think
hundo p i'm sick of seeing giancarlo
esposito play [ __ ] villains he plays
villain all the time i'm sick of it he's
very good at it and i just finished um
he's very good at it but very good at it
but it's always some variation of gus
fring from breaking bad it's right
always some version
i agree it is kind of uh it's kind of
like the rock is always himself warren
you know hi warren are there any updates
on tasm three usama faizal wants to know
zama um here are the rumors that i've
heard uh sony still wants to work with
andrew garfield
they have not
really clarified if that is a tasm three
or if it's some type of other
spider-verse film or if he's gonna be
the main spider-man of the new sony
verse now sony's kind of like
because in madame webb they're now
having like a baby peter parker in it
right excited for it but madame webb is
also a multiverse movie well the
character is a multiverse character
right she's essentially a cosmic entity
she has the ability to go into other
universes so we don't know if that's
gonna be the main sony universe like or
if it's like some random universe that
baby peter parker is in right and you
know we have mary parker is pregnant we
don't really know what's happening there
um sorry that's like off the topic of
andrew garfield he could be the main
man
of the sony universe uh it just depends
uh but i haven't had i haven't heard
any like official confirmation about
chasm three unfortunately it's funny
seeing you here because i can hear you
in my voice and once you start going off
it's like all the city your videos are
all over again
and that's what i do for my remember
when we first met you're like oh you
script your videos mike no i don't yeah
he doesn't even research
he just kind of wings it makes it up on
the spot god managed to get all the
spider-man no way home correct
just from bullshitting his way through
it's like what do you know you're
throwing up at the wall you might
actually
actually get some theories right let me
tell you what was just a great
conversation um
speaking to sony before the spider-man
no way home premiere and just kind of
like yeah no once i see the film i won't
share anything i promise even though i
shared your whole movie
already i promise once i see it i won't
say anything that was a fun conversation
to have
scout's honor
so john spencer in the chat's asking
when do you think deadpool's gonna show
up oh funny you pulled the exact
question i was gonna throw to warren i
think it'll be before deadpool 3.
uh i think it would be really funny and
a fun surprise if they did it during
she-hulk because of the elephantine
fourth wall break in the room nah i'm
talking about that yeah i think that
would be clever i think deadpool's gonna
show up at the post-credits scene of
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness ah he's gonna be in the prison
and he's gonna show up there which sets
us up and we're finally gonna get
mutants really introduced
once the multiverses collide together i
double down on that that's gonna happen
yes definitely i haven't seen multiverse
and madness yet but i think that's
what's going to happen guys yes you're
exactly you're 100 right
yes siree babarino jake hedge what's up
man oh roman reigns for the mcu oh yeah
roman reigns would be a great lobo for
the mcu yes
yes mcu's logo definitely hey uh wasn't
squirrel girl in production aren't they
working out a squirrel girl i thought
squirrel girl was was trying to be a
thing no nothing i haven't heard that
well guys
actually warren and i were talking about
this um a couple hours ago uh saying do
you think marvel has too much content we
understand we got some super chats we
will get to them soon guys uh thank you
for everyone who has contributed so far
um but francesca's asking do you think
marvel has too much content right now
and upcoming
warren just earlier so you mentioned
this yeah you were telling me how you
think marvel's really fumbling the ball
right now that's not what i said he said
i don't understand why i keep doing
marvel videos when i hate everything
marvel's doing
so do you want to finally come clean
about how you really think do you want
to come clean yeah we're
hulking it too much
i mean just before this live stream you
were telling me that mcu stood for most
crappy universe so
so um
that's why you're here warren's joining
the real rejects because he can no
longer support uh marvel shillings come
on the real region
and uh i have to edit all their videos
and basically do everything for them
because they have to pay me now
uh i
want to clarify i did not say any of
that
just to clarify and put that on the
record um but no you take a look
at everything they announced and also
like i feel like they
didn't announce everything like i am
groot wasn't on there but granted that
was like 20 minutes all together 25
minutes or something like that um
but there could actually be more yeah
and there there's a lot let's let's just
be honest there's a lot and my concern
is that if you are
doing so much
it's obviously going to get less
attention
because you have to move on to the next
thing you have to finish this in time
to be able to to do the next thing on
time so it's like
you know
do you cut corners is the cgi if it's
things like that right like because the
sheet trailer came out and everyone's
like yo what is up with the cgi and uh
you know we can't really talk about
she-hulk but um
the the cgi
could be better
sure that's what the problem is without
marvel's glut of content
it's it's do you i don't know if it's
money i know it's time right right i
know it's time i don't know if it's like
a money thing they only have a certain
budget and that's where some things uh
slack on like
we gotta pay everybody and then oh cgi
it's like uh that's good enough right
that's the risk i think that
that marvel takes on with doing too much
because look like okay
before
like what
three years ago it was like oh three
marvel movies a year
and now it's like what five six disney
plus shows alone in like three four
movies like that's a lot to just ramp up
over
you know and they went from like okay
this is like the last time we're doing
this to like so it's like the year
before three projects the year after
like six projects like it was very quick
too
so
you're not
you're supposed you're supposed to say
nothing but positive things about marvel
and you're kind of
we're gonna
we're supposed to get a direct deposit
today
and if i guess that's already in the
bank
oh we're good oh then [ __ ] marvel
until the next check is about to arrive
[Laughter]
guys alvin
wants to know if bucky will ever get a
show or movie for himself do you think
it's possible
possible yes will it probably happen now
no no i don't see that but
like well of course it's possible do you
think it's actually possible in this
paradigm that we're seeing is it
possible that i'll play wolverine yes am
i going to no
i i think what we're talking about with
with marvel is we don't really get time
to miss them sometimes sure you know
yeah we get like two weeks to miss them
you get time to miss certain characters
i uh because i hear people like
obviously i love marvel
and i don't feel the marvel fatigue but
i can get how other people
feel that yeah right and i and i've seen
a lot of people say like i'm not
watching this show i'm not watching this
show i don't care i don't care blah blah
blah blah i get that
and i'm sure there's channels out there
and this is a good idea for me to do a
series recap for the people who actually
don't want to fully watch
you know whatever moon knight she-hulk
miss marvel true what you know
i get it because there's a lot
hey uh i think we're we got we got like
a little bit of super chat so i want to
make sure that we don't neglect the
people who contributed to us so we want
to give them some little extra tlc but
we're going through the chat appreciate
every comment that's coming in please
keep doing it
please keep coming in with them comments
while john's loading that um hey warren
what's up who is your wolverine pick top
pick me
besides you
you narcissistic son of a [ __ ]
another universe
does that count
i think uh
people are really you know i used to
kind of be ambivalent towards the taran
edgerton pick and i've seen people in
the chat pointing out taryn edgerton
specifically adrian
uh however i am
i have come around to the taran
edgertinpic
i like it
i'm glad we have i
if i'm re okay if well it's not
realistic i would love a younger keanu
reeves obviously we can't do that
no
no we're not going to
um i like taren i like a lot i like him
a lot he's met with marvel studios
and
they've at least had to have talked
about that role what if we're all wrong
and the role that giancarlo esposito met
for was wolverine this whole time all
right you know what that's my number one
i am a man with claws
[Laughter]
i will slash you
you got it i am going to unfurl those
claws but i'm going to slash
[Laughter]
he monologues his way through everything
yeah he just does it with reality
just called off work for this thank you
buddy don't make a living just be here
now with us that's all you got to do
hanging you took it a step further you
donated money yeah man thank you you
should not make money today
we're gonna have to work more to make up
for what you've lost next time but thank
you well we're glad to have you with us
and we hope it's a good way to spend
your afternoons thank you
robbie brown
hello dads just wanted to send some love
from scotland
robbie brown thank you so much we are
your three fathers hold on hold on i'm
gonna mix up the sound effects my
family's from edinburgh these
technically are supposed to be voice
changers
[Music]
the mcu
uh
oh
accurate looking version
yes just just chris tell chris thought
i think you should
[Music]
thank you md
all right
[Music]
these are all voice filters on page two
wait so no one just heard our voices
like that just us well because we're not
hearing it on any of the channels and so
i think if we're not hearing it it's not
oh my god our voice is the voice teacher
is happening i'm so sorry oh good
i told you i told you i was like dude
there's no way they understand what
we're doing
i'm so sorry i know this is a large
robot voice right now
this is a small robot
and then they have uh a sensor but
desert
if you leap yourself out if you just
want to say a big fat
you know you got a little beep there i'm
sorry guys
they can't understand i'm sorry
that was my fault i just hit a random
button and i done messed up i'm sorry
yes how how long was that on for it was
a few it was like a few minutes
it wasn't two minutes but it was a
little bit of time
people are so pissed off i'm so funny
i'm so sorry
i can't i was like i could barely
understand what you guys were saying
there's no way to pitch us up right now
oh you you when we gotta cut it out
i feel like no they're not people this
is actually how we sound see now now we
have the voice filled this is actually a
voice filter right now they're done we
always use voice they're done oh yeah
yeah we sound the high squeaky i'm so
sorry everyone
no i mean you guys should see i do like
everything all righty guys
okay fantastic all right really quick so
i think the thing should be played by uh
joel edgerton
and uh i think um
joel letters if you were so bad i'm so
sorry
we lost half the chat you're only
focusing on the people who are mad and
not the ones who love it what happened
it's definitely a split
people totally died
it's totally down and then i think uh
the human torch should be uh daiquiri
montgomery
and then i i think uh the invisible
woman
uh
should be the the girl from it follows
and uh that is that i don't know her
name and then uh mr stretchy guy uh
stretchy guy
change his name uh mr mr fantastic mr
stretchy guy mr fantastic i do like that
penn badgley pick however i'm gonna go
with um
uh
what's so who's john who's who's mr mr
fantastic my mister fantas okay i'll
just give you all my four right now my
mr fantastic uh we are going to go
with oh i had his name in mind hold on a
second
for ben graham i'm going tor johnson sue
storm katherine hepburn uh i'm gonna do
johnny storm's gonna be errol flynn and
we're gonna have mr fantastic be played
by carrie grant
nice gary grant yeah that's a that's
pretty good john i really like that
warren speed around it um i want john
cena to play all four roles oh that
would be great yes
oh he'd be a great invisible one he
would be a great invisible he would be
he can't see him
exactly right
um yeah i go with all white cast always
yes always a white cast uh i think i
think if you try any other ethnicity
you're trying too hard plain and simple
your virtue signaling yeah
that's like the last movie i don't know
what um i i like krasinski do you not
want him to be the main
mr fantastic i think okay john krazinski
is mr fantastic yeah
jenna fisher as the invisible woman
steve corral she wouldn't be bad i've
never thought about that the human torch
steve
rayne wilson as the thing is how i would
do it
this is why you don't work for marvel
jonathan caitlin this is why they pay us
we've given many many real responses
many times over the years
i know i know i know all right we got
our boy dakota jones here i'd love
javier bardem as doom oh you've created
a monster
uh to me it's the perfect casting with
his look from sky phone his accent
if true and he dies what if ant-man
that's a scroll all that and more coming
up on today's mcu breakdown
what do you think guys
i think we should do
doing everything we've all done before
and just do this
um i think uh javier bardem is dr doom
again is it's a great pick
uh but it's it's very generic to me
but but do you wanna i feel like i want
a little younger
how young are we talking
not like
our age maybe like
45.
that's fair
right i guess who would be a good 45
year old who'd be a white guy who would
be a good 45 well like how good 45 year
old dmc um
let's see how old was robert downey jr
when he first played iron man
uh 45 i think he was in his 40s right
yeah he was like around that age
yeah
that's your answer i want a 45 year old
yes
everybody age appropriate really
45 year old you're welcome
adam scott
adam scott yeah i love him he's awesome
he's all over the place now really
who would be a great um
god that is a ben stiller we're talking
about doom
yeah
who would you be your doom pick
i feel like you might have a good one
nailed down yeah uh i had a really good
one uh and i'm blinking right now i do
think viggo mortensen would be an
awesome pick and it's very sincere note
i feel like uh vigo bourne is going to
be a cool doctor doom maybe he's not 45
but he would be a good pick i think oh
does
dizzy
you know that is the determining factors
that will determine whether i say yes or
no this is going to be the research
computer in front of us today you would
do it do it do it they can't see people
really want killian murphy as dr doom
i've seen that in the chat quite a bit i
mean he's a tiny tiny guy but i mean
movie magic give me him i always love a
good killing
vegan mortensen age we're going to look
up right now
he is he's older
he's five foot eleven that's for sure
here's my question about him though what
is the last thing he's done fico
mortensen has done so much [ __ ] i
haven't seen him in anything he just
gotten a nomination for the green book
like two years ago and he did mr
fantastic or captain fantastic
his face looks like a mask killian
murphy so he also has a really good
like
he could play like a rich guy yeah like
a inception like yeah that character
right there um
and he's he's a runner off his runner
for batman
well yeah and then he ended up playing
scarecrow yeah some people are saying
that uh that ray fines would make a good
doctor doom i think he would but then
again i mean killing murphy's a little
bit like he looks like a villain and it
would be fun
he's played a varied enough cannon of
characters that it would be fun to see
him be a big bad i feel like yeah ray
finds has been big bads and big goods
and everything true people don't like my
mortensen pick they're saying he's too
old in the chat
you guys disagree with me again i'm
putting back the high-pitched voice i
actually people like the high-pitched
guy
i didn't like the other one i i think i
agree i think he's too old adam driver
dr doom
i think uh cage doctor doom we're with
you jake hedge uh let's see here thank
you dakota absolutely robbie brown's
back robbie brown he's saying i love
simon baker as doom thinking he can ace
the calm intelligent side of doom let's
look up simon baker from the mentalist
yeah he's a suave cat he's i was gonna
say that he's suave yeah he is suave
um my mom was very attracted to simon
baker
what's uh oh my gosh so she might get
into the marvel cinematic universe now
that simon baker can be doctor doom i
can't figure it in gerard butler i've
heard that one before i am doctor
i am
[Laughter]
why wouldn't you want that perfect i
don't want gerard butler to do anything
because he just can't do an accent
very very well give him a scottish
character
what no one's done it needs to happen uh
hey robbie brown thank you for the baker
love
border
trade porter says sup guys suck trip
border good to see you trey porter not
much man just here live streaming what's
up with you not gonna lie whenever i
meet a guy named trey i always assume
they are an intimidating alpha trey trey
cool
mustafa jav oh wait these are sound
effects i mean not not voice changers
right yes all right a warren
say stop
12.
god damn you are you are doing you're
not doing a good job here here's an easy
rule of thumb if you're on page two
these buttons down here will be red
cool yeah mustafa
says would you like spike lee to direct
a third black panther film
i would love to see them do that what
black panther film be like
he could infuse some of that because
sometimes you get like that spike lee
who could have fun with a little bit of
that black exploitation vibe yeah and i
think that'd be a pretty cool thing to
infuse with black panther get one of
those hallway shots of black panther and
nokia or something like that
not moving but still tracking down the
hall
yeah and then there will be like a
montage of real-life footage at the end
or be a serious social commentary
definitely a bad white guy in it it'll
be both man it'll be it'll be the
exploitation fun spike but it'll also be
woke ass spike too you know
it'll be peak both and and i'm here for
it i want i want i do i don't know i
think i have to be very curious if i
cannot see spike lee cooperating with
marvel to adhere to what they would want
to do that's probably true i think spike
leaves i don't yell at kevin feige
i don't see his top priority being the
canon and the continuity
probably not huh i'm seeing will smith
and johnny depp is doomed arnold
schwarzenegger is doctor doom oh that
would be great pinned it down right now
let's just do it actually alexander
skarsgard is doomed not a bad pick yeah
random all right warren which color i'm
gonna go with uh this cantaloupe looking
one why would you even ask me okay i'm
gonna go with this blue one
oh that's pleasant beautiful thank you
for the super chat random beautiful do
you john do you guys think that we're
going to get an mcu x-men mutants movie
before secret wars warren cosmic wonder
i really really hope so and think if
they don't
we rise that would be a bad decision i
was convinced they were going to
announce something about mutants at
comic con they're waiting for d23 they
have to have something to announce for
d23 because feige teased mutants in the
last comic con this is like the last
thing he said at the last comic con was
fantastic for mutants end of sdcc 2019
and i was like i really want him to just
start it with like so the last thing i
said was this let's talk about this
it's been three years or however yeah
and that's what i really want him to do
i
i think
mutants will be addressed at d23 they
have to be i mean even miss marvel had
the mutation thing brought up so i
thought like right they aren't going
that way it perfectly makes sense that
they would have mutation brought up and
then we would have mutants introduced in
lusting foggies so it really seemed
like a likely scenario didn't it john it
did 100 percent fixed so likely to me i
was just sitting there going the
likelihood of this is good well
especially because like two weeks before
that episode feige was like yeah you're
all about to see where it's going how
it's connecting and then all of a sudden
it's like yeah yeah mutation it's like
ah
yeah so i i would be surprised if they
did not have a solo mutant x-men whether
it's just about mutants or the actual
team i would be shocked if they didn't
actually have a movie before secret wars
yeah
i think they i i think they should
i think they should i feel like there
will be mutants but i feel like phase
seven is where the big like exit yeah
thing is gonna happen see m11 rrs and
the chat said seemed intentionally they
didn't mention mutants at all at comic
con
and that's because they have to have
something
big to talk about at d23 i mean they
revealed the kang dynasty and secret
wars and the fantastic four date like
that's that's big like that's really big
i think they were pressured too due to
some leaks that happen
oh yeah the day before yeah that was why
the literal day before i don't know
i'm still curious about that because i
don't know it seems like it makes sense
with the timeline
because why would they need to register
that stuff if not to do the announcement
yeah they did register it like the day
before and they registered new world
order and some other types of the ones
that they were also yeah that makes
sense that makes sense i think it's a
little odd
that they would reveal the last movies
from their phase six
but not the ones before because i think
the big thing like what if they
announced like hey guess what wolverine
movie like people will lose their minds
now i don't think that's gonna happen
right but
there was um
what if all of phase six is just a
wolverine movie a psychologist
gambit which he's actually backed
wonder they held yeah
i seen ewan mcgregor or hayden
christensen doom evan mcgregor does not
want to be in the mcu he just talked
about it he just said don't even suggest
it he said i'm in this thing called the
star wars universe
and now i'm feuding with mark ruffalo
reed coles thanks for the super chat
here's your sound effect no don't do
that one
sorry
told you not to
hey do you guys think blade will uh set
up midnight sons and uh
thoughts on the johnny blaze poster and
she hulk um
well
we've seen
wait did you guys see that episode all
right guys look i'm gonna ask you guys a
question in the chat right now and be
very honest with me i'm gonna have to
put out a poll
so
um we did record our reactions uh john
and i and coy to the first two episodes
of she-hulk and now there's
at the premiere launch event yesterday
uh they
we didn't know this they like until it
happened that they were gonna play
episode three and four
and i did mention nikoi like if they
play episode three
and four john and i are gonna leave are
gonna have to leave the theater because
we we haven't recorded our reaction for
it now there's
many people who will attest to john and
i actually some people don't believe us
when we say this but there's many people
who will you were right next to me that
we bolted the second episode two was
done we bolted out of there and we just
waited for the event to end so we didn't
watch it because we wanted to wait to
react to it you just lied to your family
i just lied to them yeah i watched it i
know everything's gonna happen i'm gonna
predict it in the moment and then i'm
gonna just be like cuz look how good i
am it's like i ran with you guys and i
was like yeah i'll just uber at home
yeah i guess you guys are gonna leave um
but uh but mccoy ended up uh he couldn't
get out of the theater so he's like i
guess i'm watching three and four so
he's already seen it and i was like well
dude you can't be in the video if you've
already seen it like the gate's the
whole point of the reaction
that's what koi said but you were like
nah you can fake it just be in the video
i did say you can fake it no one can
tell we do it all the time
uh no i saw it i already got it we got
into a little debate about he's like i
could do the review i'm like maybe but
you've already seen episode four so it
doesn't really make sense yeah uh yeah
so uh
yeah so that's the position that we're
in it's like do we bring coy back
to react with us even though he's
already seen it
that's kind of like the can yeah can i
say something no yes all right what is
it no tell me something really nice
about about what about you oh you and
john what did we do
you said no all right
moving on cool
all right unless i know you're expecting
me to jump in
unless no i've actually um
i've known greg and john for a bit now
and yeah no um
i really respected that you left
oh really i really respected that you
guys left i was like
because i appreciate i appreciate
genuinenuity what's that
genuineness
yours is doing so good
you're doing so good
i appreciate
how genuine you guys are with your
reactions
and the fact that you guys left i
i respect it as a cause i don't know if
you guys know this i watched the real
rejects like before i knew them like
years before i actually knew them so
this is kind of funny that we're like
really good friends now yeah yeah um but
you know i've always loved their
reactions and uh after getting to know
the both of them i'm like it's like it's
even greater if you know how genuine
they are so it was kind of a surreal
moment because i was like
that was really cool
as i was like but i'm gonna stay and
watch all the episodes but i don't react
to things right so it's like yeah i did
have ryan airy messaging me the other
day he's like wait
so you actually are watching that for
the first time he said that to me about
something and it was like i thought
maybe you watched it and then you just
re-recorded moments for certain moments
like that's a lot of editing to do for
those shows and movies i'm like there's
only one way to do it man
we gotta watch it for the first time
yeah yeah
that's funny anyway
the real question rick coles we didn't
answer him do you think blaze will blade
will set up midnight suns and thoughts
on the johnny blaze poster and she-hulk
yes um i do think blade will set up
midnight sons i feel like we have been
getting a setup for that and night and
also um johnny blaze poster and she-hulk
i mean there's a lot i i
i saw in the trailers i don't know yet
but i saw the main theory going i'm
gonna intentionally make you not talk
about it i can't talk about it because
you probably know the answer perhaps um
but for me
before where we're at i mean we we it
took us a while even though we did that
reaction it took us a while to realize
oh wait that doesn't spell johnny you
can't it's
i told i think i think
there's not enough letters oh [ __ ] what
did i do
if there's no h though what if he's a
jonathan in this universe but in the one
one of the tr you said it when we were
watching like oh they're making ghost
writer a magician and then one of the
trailers they showed a magician
character so i was like oh it's got to
be that guy okay so it's a mystery
unless it's a fake out johnny blaze very
yeah donnie plays logan b and the chat's
pointing it out yeah exactly yeah
yeah this is the other logical d the
ideological letter reynalda torres
torres super chat in the house
it's a good one
good sound effect super chat
super chat ow hey guys quick question
what makes dr doom so powerful i've only
ever known him from the fantastic four
movies and he's been defeated each time
i don't know he's actually an extremely
powerful sorcerer let me go on wikipedia
oh he's an extremely powerful sorcerer
you're gonna know okay
one of my favorite story lines
ever is where uh cynthia von doom dr
doom's mother
uh actually
gets trapped in the hell dimension by
mephisto and dr doom is an extremely
powerful sorcerer
but he actually gets the help of doctor
strange and they go to the hell
dimension to try to get cynthia von doom
back it's a crazy great comic story line
i love it uh they succeed ish she goes
to another plane to where she can
communicate with victor von doom she
doesn't actually fully escape but she's
not trapped like in the actual hell
dimension with mephisto anymore what are
you doing i'm going to be um
i'm taking notes
no he's he's an incredibly powerful
sorcerer he really is like
he gives wanda a run for her money i
mean he's stronger yeah uh well that i
shouldn't say that he he gives a run for
money though he he's very powerful so
and they don't really they don't depict
that in
the movies
they don't ever depict the sorcery part
that's what i'm saying like they don't
actually show them like the magical side
of him which is to me is like the
coolest part of him magic is silly and
for children well he's got like the
genius
side yeah he's a genius he's like the
genius science side of like a reed
richards and a tony stark but he's also
got like the mystical side of a um
of a doctor strange yeah yeah that's a
basic way to say it yeah
oh yeah i helped out koi's video i know
i know it
[Laughter]
zack keel thank you for the contribution
over at the stream labs we very much
appreciate you uh zack keel wants to
know do you guys think
there you go there's your sound
do you guys think the next spider-man
will be in the next avengers movie or is
he officially done with the avengers and
going solo from now on how no way home
ended thanks for keeping me entertained
with your content every day
best movie channel on youtube thank you
zack keel do you think spider-man will
be in the next avengers oh yeah i think
secret wars he's got to be in it it
would be a shame if they missed the
opportunity to
give him the venom symbiote suit and
secret wars because that's how it
originates from the comics
um i think that would be really cool but
i mean i'm expecting all three
spider-man and secret wars at least yeah
right
i mean
missed opportunity if not look secret
wars just has to be like every five
minutes there's a cameo
i think i really feel like i don't even
care if it doesn't feel like a real
movie because it's like
go hog wild and just cameo bananas in
that one and i'll be like wow that was a
trip and uh walk out of the theater
three and a half hours of a character
entering frame i wouldn't mind that i
actually want that i really wouldn't
mind it just because it's secret wars
that's the whole point is like all the
universes collide with each other all
the variants are together if we don't
get that i'm gonna be
really disappointed and like i
understand what was
happening in the mcu with multiverse of
madness with loki they were like
guiding us
to what is about to come yeah they're
like establishing rules of the universe
and such like that even though true i
feel like multiverse of madness was a
little bit misleading in their marketing
especially with spiderman knowing home
and like the trailer was like
you know
you messed with the fabric of the
multiverse and and doctor strange is
like i did what i had to do and stuff
like that but really it had nothing to
do
especially when you put that trailer
right at the end of spider-man right
exactly they it's like but they didn't
really connect at all
but i think i personally thought
that
multiverse and madness was going to go
to a lot of different universes like and
not like really quickly but like in the
universe some type of a story some type
of a plot see a character bunch of
characters go to another one the same
thing happens i thought it was going to
be time in a lot of different universes
and i think that's what secret wars
needs to be
those sons of [ __ ] yeah no they have to
or just a bunch of them come into one
universe well why
well no right that's what i mean but why
do the secret war storyline
if you're not gonna have all the cameos
all the different variants like
why do it like just do a different
avengers film and then do after secret
wars they should do a very grounded
movie about like an i am legend with
just one superhero in the earth one hero
one time just
just wondering what the planet almost
maestro hulk
he's the last remaining super did you
see that you see oh my god knowledge
knowledge in that i make a dummy joke
and he comes in here with like well
actually
[ __ ] deep cut for you oh
[Music]
all right we're we're
we're we're we're calm now we're back to
zero okay flev doran what'd you say
flevtavius dorino i don't have any
original suggestion i just came to say
hi
and i would love to see hugh jackman
back as wolverine in the upcoming
deadpool film it'll make a great moment
as reynolds lobbied both in real life
and in the film to bring him in
i love that no i think i think that's
when we could get that actual
cameo what are you looking at are you
looking at the chat on the phone yeah
that's amazing so i can see it guys
listen new rockstars is live right now
so i'm just going to leave a comment yes
uh new rock stars let's do it right and
now i'm going to be like
if coy's there is coy there i don't know
he's not there on irma i'm not going to
troll since koi not
i don't want to be bad i don't want it
yeah it was one of their if if corey's
not there then i would just look like a
dick because i don't really know there's
other people
eric carrera or carrier i'm not sure how
to say your name but spielberg for
fantastic four i actually think that
could be cool
uh all right john can we put the can we
can we uh refresh this yeah that's why i
pulled
all right let's see here
we did talk about giancarlo earlier
you're gonna have to rewind the stream
start it all over again from the very
beginning don't skip anything at all i
wanna i also wanna thank joe bucky
barnes
um
for helping us moderate this again by
the way
bucky if there's any way you want us to
like shout out specifically you know the
oh kenny's asking do you think morbius
will be in super wars i think it would
be a missed opportunity if morbius is
not in secret wars i don't think
rewards bring him in
i think
you guys
you got you don't know what you're
talking about cosmic morbid time i don't
ever talk about this stuff i think
everyone should be in dire jeopardy
it is the doom
the moment
and and there's like not a chance at
home like oh my god are they going to
actually kill them off
and then you just hear off-screen it's
morbid
camera pants over to jere leto and he's
all vampired out
it should just be the sony version
should be like craven and madame webb
[ __ ] old ass um anastasia
that's an actress
you mean dakota
she
yeah you just have old ass dakota
johnson in a chair it should be it
should be the sony verse that saves the
day i think that would be so funny
yeah that's what kevin feige is gonna do
yeah i think if kevin feige gets [ __ ]
over he should do that just to go for
the marvel cinematic universe you know
what cuz
i'm i'm out just and then it pans over
to kevin feige who takes off his marvel
hat then puts on a dc hat and then snaps
his fingers and
then all the universe goes away and then
all of a sudden michael keaton shows up
in between all of them
well i hope the food's better in this
joint
oh yes it's going to be a great great
great one i do think it would be a
missed opportunity though
to do morbid time
come on they should do morbid time in
the next morbius movie they should no
they should do it in the actual mcu he
should pop up somewhere
in deadpool he should pop up in deadpool
and just randomly say it that'd be so
good right yeah that's something you
could do in deadpool now that the
multiverse is established in the mcu
that's true or deadpool could say it but
i think it would be funny if morbius
just randomly popped up
said it and then left and deadpool made
a funny comment about it guys i'm not
going to do any um
i don't i want to just make this clear
since we're talking about deadpool i
want to say that i'm not talking i'm not
saying there's a tease for deadpool at
all and she'll listen well we saw it i
didn't see any teasers for deadpool
i just want to mention that
i think the post-credits scene of the
first episode of deadpool i mean she
helped i was like what what
i'm hitting
so confirmed i promise you there's no
deadpool hint in that episode all right
i don't want to mislead people into
thinking i'm saying that
uh you're a millionaire uh i am a
millionaire oh my gosh yeah
i i'm married into a very rich family
and uh i killed my wife and i took her
money
insurance money you never know um eric
vos got married that's why you haven't
seen eric boston over a week
so congratulations to eric voss speaking
of character in the chat
is asking in chat but the first
post-credits scene in she-hulk is
hilarious it's one of my favorite
post-credits scenes like i said it and
then i re-watched it again and i'm like
yeah that's one of my favorite
post-credits scenes it is it is it is
it's like a big setting i don't want to
set expectations none of those it's just
a really good post credit it's a great
post credit scene i i said this in my
video today they're gags
sure
yeah that's a good way to put it yeah
they're gags they're funny yeah yeah i
wouldn't take now we won't talk about
you
um yeah hi from brazil hey carolina i
love when other people from other
countries are here oi
it's good to see you um do we have more
tarde yes uh inside the horseshoe
podcast start the whole video over
montrell
hey guys it's matt beer
friend of the channel matt beer i hope
all three of you guys are having a
fantastic day we are now thank you this
is like actually hanging out with us on
the stream yeah you can stand for a
little bit i know sometimes you need to
stand for that sure i've swapped like
legs that i'm sitting on and got you
yeah neil those google net worths are
almost never accurate does it say i'm
worth 150 million
is that what it says on google then
you're owed money contact the government
i don't think people understand what net
worth means yeah net worth is like
encompassing everything everything you
own yeah right so with that they're
actually way off it's like 500 million
yeah i'm worth like half a billion
dollars you're worth two great men and a
half
uh thank you matt beer miss you bud
spencer jensen thanks for those
super chat spence gents oh my god we got
nick anderson from alabama in the chat
here yep spencer this this this one's
directed at you he says love you warren
oh thank you now this was brought up
earlier so i want to i want you to give
a very efficient answer here do you
think the mgu
no no he said mcu sorry that was my
subconscious projecting my
agenda
um
do you think the mcu was worrying more
about quantity than quality well we
talked about this a little bit i know
but some people come in here a little
bit late and then they contribute to the
super chat i understand
some love
i'm going home
no don't
please i'm going home
spencer
thanks for the
money that they get um
hey man no thank you for being here no
seriously thank you spencer um
i
i think they should slow down a bit
but i think it's only because you can
only work
so hard without getting burnt out so i'm
not even saying like right now they're
doing too much but i think to keep up
this pace
it's gonna be really hard true like
really really hard and to keep up the
quality as to your point
of doing so much quantity is hard the
more you do the harder it is to
have really great quality
consistently so yeah i do think
it might slack a little bit but
knowing kevin feige
and kind of his
like standards like i think it'll always
be okay and i think if there ever is
something that's like wow that was bad i
think they will take time and reassess
their entire plan yeah and say hey maybe
we do need to slow it down a little bit
and kind of focus back on that quality
but i mean
i think the quality has been fine yeah
so far like
this
is always subjective right whether you
like it or not it's always great it's
marvel it's always good
oh it's good never bad we got the check
already wait did we get the check out
this did you see the check coming out
coming thank you sure you guys got
checked oh wait john never gets it but i
gotta check that yeah no you can say
about that that's why john's honest and
not mainstream you can say about that i
just get checks from rob zombie
okay my favorite halloween monsters is
awesome i'm gonna watch the monsters and
i'm going to be just as excited as i was
before but see mike 2021 says wasn't
this pace caused by the two-year delay
coveted cause listen guys i think we're
also gonna we're also gonna have to
change the title of this video because
we have not been doing with the title of
this
it video off that way did not turn into
that um but yeah i mean he's got a point
because because you know they did have a
backlog of things they couldn't release
and things trailing up and even though
it looks like phase five
at least is gonna be pretty packed along
with phase four i still feel like we're
sort of dealing with this
uh yeah just like coming back to a
normal clip after the pandemic so i
don't know i'm curious to see how they
adjust yeah i think it's i think they're
all right right now spencer um
and that is a great point brought up is
yeah they had kind of like a stockpile
of stuff right because of the pandemic
true um but
based off of what we've seen from phase
five reveal and what whatever we're
gonna see from phase six
they sound like quality projects they
really do so i hope they do them
with a great quality and if they don't i
think they should i think they would
they will i think some will have more
qualitative care than others well you
also have to keep in mind like
the disney plus shows they just aren't
like as far as like
all the edit like cgi and stuff like
that they're not going to be as good as
the movies like
you don't know that loki looked great
and everybody was fantastic and then it
got down right
yeah but since then right it's uh
and i've
i've enjoyed
no i lied i didn't like what if i
it's the only one i couldn't enjoy what
if f4 is great um have any of us
accidentally spoil something we watch
early i haven't i'm really i'm really
good about that
no you told them dead numbers we have a
very important
question in the chat from logan b about
greg's red daredevil beanie then put the
super chats away for a hot minute so we
can show which where we're paying
attention okay hold on so we're going to
bring this here then so you guys know
great someone gave a 50. i can't wait to
read that one greg do you still have to
collect it
so you still have the red daredevil
beanie for episode reactions or are you
going to stick with the yellow one
you're wearing now since he has a yellow
suit i don't oh no
um no
no
i have committed that for every she-hulk
reaction i am going to wear my green
loki shirt because it's my only green
marvel shirt
and i'm going to wear my red beanie it's
i'm going to wear the same clothes every
episode
for nine weeks
because
it's it's the only color pattern that's
going to match with what i want to do
if alex i see you yeah man yeah
all right woofie woof woof back to the
soups
back to the soups guys follow soups on
his youtube channel let's go
let's go to soups's youtube channel
subscribe subscribe
what do you think uh i hope i said your
first name right uh what do you think
about the possibility of mutants having
existed in the mcu but xavier using
cerebro to erase their memories in the
past it would make some sense
wouldn't you think it makes some sense
some sense okay don't think it makes
some sense
it makes a little bit of some sense
right just i'm just not gonna say yes
because i don't wanna agree with greg
just because he pushed so hard
it's just a little bit disgusting
is there a laugh track here
no it's just the people clapping i think
i'm a [ __ ]
yeah i mean well
there's not a laugh track but you know
we do have
someone say something funny
something funny
no i mean i think that
i think the thing about mutants is you
know
with charles xavier like what's it going
to be with their introduction in the mcu
is it going to be a hodgepodge of
multiverses colliding together because
with the way miss marvel sets it up
is oh there's mutation in your dna so
it's like this is the start and the rise
of mutants but then
what about that whole thing with are we
going to get xavier introduced and then
he's going to start up a school for the
gifted will
can i interrupt sorry
yeah you can interrupt why not yeah i'm
going to interrupt go for it
well greg do you watch my videos uh most
of them yeah
i do listen to most of them
um i do i really do they were here they
released i listened to it i could vouch
for that yeah they released
concept art that showed uh avengers con
for miss marvel mm-hmm somebody wearing
the cyclops cyclops and it had that
remember that from your video i'm sure
you do uh
remember that's how i learned about it
you're probably watching heavy spoilers
uh no i don't think he mentioned that
and uh i didn't watch his breakdown i'm
sure that that's call paul and check
call him paul
i'll text him
um well that came it came out like
a week ago two weeks ago or something
like so it was way after you know the
show aired right well
i guess not way after but um
the fact that they made the concept art
with cyclops wearing the x-men logo
pretty much means the x-men team already
does exist is that why they cancel
batgirl you would think they pulled [ __ ]
like that yeah that's right that's
exactly what that came with that's right
they put the pictures
of one shot and they were like nah this
is too soon bro definitely not yeah
cancel but to that point though that
would mean that maybe they have existed
and we just
haven't been hearing about them well
which would be a bummer well kamala's
mute
gene was just activated so i'm assuming
professor x picks up on that
and says hey yo
you're a
that's quality over quantity you know
and now speaking of quality tony danza
and a wheelchair
you guys want a professor x wake up
right here we're just gonna have great
speaking of quality over quantity i do
think that there is something to be said
and it's all marvel and it's all
connected so you can still get fatigue
but i feel like they do a better job at
aiming in different directions with all
this stuff so like not everything is for
the same demographic even though it's
all trying to swing very wide and i feel
like that's what separates it from a
star wars where not to not to you know
do this wow mark ruffalo well no but i
get what he's saying is that in the mcu
while there are certain like you know
story beats and blah blah blah like they
do seem to be trying to be a studio that
makes like you know marvel is their
franchise but really they have a bunch
of franchises within that whereas star
wars seems to mostly have
its core thing but anyway uh
warren
dj sniper
wants to know what the story is with
woof woof oh
okay
oh okay so
i'm trying to remember four or five
years ago four and a half years ago a
little before miss marvel a little
before i was asleep and then someone
whispered
in my ear and i never learned
so i say it now in hopes that that
person will return to the chat and say
hey i said that to you you must say it's
the end of every video
um when i first started my channel
i uh
i it was very much for fun
and i i didn't think about things like
enunciating when i speak and i honestly
still really don't
i structure my videos a little bit
differently but um i would just talk and
it was um
it was before infinity war
yeah it was after black panther oh yeah
it was me doing a video about the black
panther post credit scene about bucky
and i said he was the white wolf
annunciate and like the next day on that
video everybody started commenting like
woof woof woof woof yeah but it was like
in a playful way not like
yo you idiot that's right yeah they're
like isn't it funny how he says woof and
not wolf jake hedge knows he's saying
he's talking something jake hedge is a
true champion he literally responded it
he got made fun of how he said wolf boom
yeah jake knows jake's jake's usually in
all the fun of your speech impediment
exactly
yeah exactly so um
which you should do with all people i
said it as a joke the next video because
everybody was like saying it and i just
said woof and then i don't know people
really
thought it was funny
and i just kept saying it and now i say
it at the end of every video just kind
of for those original subscribers
because it was when i had like 500
subscribers
so every now and then i'll i'll get
somebody in the chat don't ever change
it man and they're like hey that's so
great that you still say that like i
just pop in every now and then
you know and uh it's really awesome you
still say that so i say it as really as
a dedication to all of the people who
support the channel
um but specifically it's kind of like an
inside joke with those original people
and now you all you know there you go
wolf wolf heavy spoilers fans that's
beautiful
princess consuela banana
it was it was oh that's a friend who's
almost friends
princess consuela banana hammock and uh
crap back i love that yeah i forget that
you're a friends fan too i love friends
have you guys seen rrr have not seen rrr
no i was outside of an auditorium that
was playing it when i went to see a
different movie and it sounded fun and
everyone came everyone spontaneously
everyone just burst into flight yeah
wolfgang
that's an old-school thing
cm the killer i just haven't made the
time to go watch uh rrr yet just haven't
done it yet all seven hours they would
rather live stream with me
yes we can make time for a three hour
live stream but then to edit that down
no no no we just haven't we haven't
committed the time to it yet i have a
question yes za
says remember the hype for no way home
so i want to pose this question to y'all
no and you don't i don't remember i'm
listening
john said no by the way i'm on the
laptop right now i'm i'm i type i'm
going to try to get all the responses
going as much so i'm i'm this is me
typing
this is me typing
there you go rrr is like the biggest
sarah williamson is like the biggest
action
extravaganza in the world right now i
can't remember if it's a full-on
bollywood or if i'm gonna if i'm gonna
butcher where it's actually from
but yes um
it is uh what is that south asia south
asian film what the hell's going on what
was your question
yeah were you going to ask warren
something someone said no way home is no
way home
yeah john said something else
speaking of spoilers um
do you think the spoilers for no way
home made the movie better
or worse like okay so here's the here's
the actual question i'll pose it in a
better do you think spider-man no way
home
would have been better if you had heard
nothing about andrew garfield and toby
mcguire showing up or do you think it
would have been worse i argue it would
not have been
as good
if we heard nothing about it i think it
was better due to all the hype that was
created about yeah they're probably in
it but nobody actually like i was like
99.9 sure but there was that sliver of
doubt that's like maybe everything i've
heard was wrong even though i've talked
to the people who worked on the film and
stuff like that to me that created the
hype and when i was in the theater and
andrew garfield popped on
everybody jumped out of their seats and
yelled
and it just made it so much better
whereas i think if i was sitting in the
theater
and it was all of a sudden like andrew
garfield would be like oh that's cool
like yo it's andrew garfield like i
think it actually would have been much
more like kind of like that like people
would be like yo
but
it was since we kind of knew we were
like yes like that's it it was a
different kind of satisfaction because
it never came right out and said they're
in it right exactly so that's what i
mean by that you had that sliver of
doubt yeah i know it comes yeah yeah no
i mean
i i think if we had never found out it
would have been the most shock i think i
mean it would have been spoiled within
one day
of course
of course
yeah that faith would have been spoiled
in like one day but um i don't know i i
was satisfied with the way it happened
like i didn't walk away going like i
wish i wish this never i wish i never
knew this because
yeah for the most part i i do think
i like the alternate reality of never
having known and then being like whoa
this is [ __ ] trippy i wouldn't i i
would have i wouldn't be paying
attention to what they were saying
i would just be in my own thoughts like
hey this is happening oh my god what are
they talking about
i'm so lost in my own thoughts
i think i'll split the difference and
say that i
that's not the thing i wish i didn't
have awareness of after the movie like
it was more like okay like a lot of the
plot is in these leagues sure but uh
what i wish is that they didn't verify
directly that the villains were going to
be in there because that said to me like
even though we are still maintaining
that sliver of doubt right it's a pretty
clear conclusion that if we got all
these guys it would be weird not to have
their two spider-men corresponding
and so yeah if they had had the will
they won't they include toby and andrew
but never showed any of them in the uh
like doc ock or green goblin in the
trailers i think that would have been
the timeline
well especially since doc and the
trailer was like you're not peter
and it's just kind of like well
okay there you
go yeah care chef amp
i say dylan o'brien just watched
american assassin dylan o'brien for
which character for professor x for dr
doom some people really want uh uh dylan
o'brien as cyclops some people think
it'd be a great cyclops i think he could
be a very solid cycle isn't he like
it talks
aren't people saying you should replace
ezra miller right now that too
that's what i've heard recently about
him it's who if it's who i'm thinking
about for to place who ezra miller oh
yeah no he was one of the main he was
one of the main people uh being uh asked
to
possibly i mean at least being reported
that he would be the one right yeah and
i think he would be solid he would be a
solid he's good i do think they need to
replace ezra because he did a lot of
running already in the maze run because
now ezra is uh now now whenever i see
the flash image just the flash image not
even the ezra's flash i just
like something about that's a little
i tainted we saw him last night yeah
that guy looked like him
and i doubled i had to do double take uh
better i could have just replied this in
person
it was amazing all right
so all right ash chase
ass chase
thank you ash chase
oh [ __ ]
greetings from australia
my question got you guys is do you see
he's not king
what happened to some of those words
they were
british thank you
greetings
from australia my question you got you
guys you see kang a bigger threat than
thanos was i absolutely see king being a
better threat than thanos gang allowed
thanos to do everything he did yeah man
king can't exactly sums up perfectly
yeah that's exactly it kang literally
let thanos do everything he could have
stopped him he saw but he saw the end
yeah he wrote the end
really yeah he just wanted to have some
fun man he's the real screenwriters of
infinity war and game it's true yeah
very true actually he wrote
the mcu he is i mean even feige is
you guys you can cancel me for a lot
i'm just writing what i'm typing just to
let you guys know i'm really typing here
like 2021 says you sound like you're
from london
and also uh uh just because we were just
answering your question uh car chef amp
uh he was talking about
what's up about uh logo uh about that
about dylan o'brien playing wolverine
wolverine dylan brown wolverine
i don't know if he's intense enough
do you think he's intense enough it's
called acting have you seen hugh jackman
he's a freudian home from the townies
[Laughter]
brilliant accent it's just
he's so funny man
it's great i think hugh jackman is
insanely talented because
it seems like a totally different person
than when you watch hugh jackman in like
an interview versus wolverine you're
like these are two
totally different people yeah it's
awesome well you know do you did you
know like
he almost quit and was almost fired from
the first x-men film yeah because he was
behaving like a dumb ass wasn't he was
behaving like a wolf no yeah they said
he would he had terrible character
portrayal
he would study wolves because he didn't
know wolverines were not wolves
i've never heard that no it's a true
story
yeah it's true i so i saw him when he
did his
like musical tour yeah because he did
like the greatest showman and all that
other stuff so i saw him when he did
that and he told the story about how you
know he almost got fired how he almost
quit how
he just wasn't doing a good job and then
he just decided to do a good job
all right i guess i got a break here
yeah yeah um but no he's incredibly
talented he really is once he flips the
good switch yeah the good switch yeah he
only had the bad one bucky barnes atl
with a moment of silence and generosity
we're going to fill that up
right now with
he's been all over this chat we're going
to fill that silence with the dog
i think i nailed it all right you did
nailed it
surf four thank you joe keary as human
torch
oh he would be perfect
joe keary from stranger things oh yeah
i don't know he plays dustin
the guy with the curly hair the kid with
the curly hair and the hat
right that's your character matthew
modine
oh yes
joe curious the old guy with the white
hair uh no joke here he's don't carry
steve with the with the beautiful hair
and everyone he's sick of he's sick of
people talking about his hair i saw in
an interview this morning he's pissed
off about people talking about us here
wait who
joe play who
he'd be a great human torch i think he'd
be absolutely perfect actually i think
so i think he'd be a perfect human torch
him or doctrine montgomery
who's also with stranger things
um let's just get the whole cast to just
bring him on
all over i think uh he would really
provide the like the perfect personality
for human torch
i mean decorating montgomery can pull it
off
but he's i mean johnny storm is like
he's like a celebrity right right
just bring chris
they both be great it's a real toss-up i
don't think you go wrong with the other
one
or jim carrey for old human torch why
not let's do that too let's do that
skyler hillman what are the odds of tony
coming back in phase six
very unlikely i hope they don't do it um
i mean not
hold on define it
like
the tony stark that died or variant
because i think a variant is likely
played by robert downey jr yes you think
of robert downey jr is going to come
back in secret wars yes
that's ridiculous okay
yeah you're goddamn marbles you know
that man it's the tuesday of the 16th of
august we will revisit this you three
you really
do you think do you think he's gonna
come back for a cameo why the hell not
i
think he really wants to put it to rest
oh my yeah and patrick stewart said the
same thing in in a few years
their characters died and they say oh i
put it to rest when my character died
that was it that was done for me i
wouldn't i wouldn't write off the
possibility
especially like a few years down the
line as that will be uh but i don't
expect him to like come back and reprise
the role full-time yeah
i can see an appearance to be like i'm
older now and i helped kick this [ __ ]
off it's another big event it's the
culmination of the next phase i'll show
up for a scene why not i can see that
you're going to tell me there's not
going to be
iron man variants
in secret wars i could see variance i
don't think it would be so you just
think there's a bunch of tom cruises i
don't think
i think a tom cruise variant is more
likely than a robert downey jr i'm sure
he would love to come back and just be
on screen for like 30 seconds i think
tom cruise is gonna build a real iron
man suit because he has to do everything
real
and he's gonna go flying in there we
built an actual iron man suit probably
already has a fly-in he probably already
has a video
it's probably working with elon musk on
whatever that [ __ ] thing is in the
next mission impossible movie elon
installed the reactor into my chest
[Music]
we're doing this
ah yeah ethan williams
robert tony junior coming back as iron
man has the same chance as bucky barnes
getting his own show yeah true
that's a sucks like i said yes it is
possible
uh justin rogers no ethan will i am
ethan will i am and a lot of people in
the chat have been echoing this uh jamie
campbell bower
aka
vecna as doom would be pretty good no
he's already
he's already vector
already a big bad i don't think he he's
not a he in he's honestly not that
intimidating to me jamie campbell bauer
you don't think he's that intimidating
because i just see harry potter when i
see him that's daniel radcliffe he's not
any of the areas
no that's harry potter that's the guy
who plays certain daughters in harry
potter he's uh
grindelwald i think what no
type in his name harry are you yeah
they do flashbacks when they do
flashbacks it's a song oh yes he's the
grendel the younger one
holy balls that's why i don't find him
that intimidating oh my god is that not
him and sweeney todd that's him in
sweeney yeah but but this is who i i see
this is why i don't find him very
intimidating oh my god he's pretty he's
beautiful man
i didn't think he was pretty in stranger
things but seeing him here yeah logan
you got it todd my god oh yeah he is in
the morning this is why i don't find him
intimidating goodness
he's beautiful he's a beautiful sexy
my god i want to stroke his face well
ethan's sexy doom if you wanted jamie
campbell bauer that's what you're like
he's too small he's too young look at
the checks he's getting off he's got his
middle
body shaving him in the chat you guys
are much ass
movie magic you guys
let me bring you
people in hollywood are not as tall as
they appear on screen
um and some people have to stand on
boxes hey don't complain about this
video sync phil this video is one of is
a very fun live stream there's nothing
out and so we're here creating
by doing talking about nothing i'm just
here okay i know this is this is how we
hang out we're finally hanging out
justin rogers
um oh surprise you guys wanted to see
most in secret work he was a vampire in
twilight too sorry
um
he's gotta learn how to live stream you
gotta learn how to i feel like i'm doing
all right
all right let's start it now is the
perfect time to start a poll wait no
finish the super chat uh assistant
rogers is saying surprise you guys want
to see most in secret wars
um the surprise i would like to see most
in secret wars
would be
the sony characters all coming over and
settling to save the day
morbid time or
or
actually you know i i would be legit
surprised if we do see um
robert downey yeah because i think
they're trying to
put that they i think they want us to
really move forward
i think that's why chris evans is
committed to not returning either
do you think chris evans is going to
come back yeah
for for secret wars cameo i don't see it
happening
i just want my makeup in your eyes open
your eyes man
with your [ __ ] third eye
doctor strange it
ah i don't know yes because this is what
my confidence needs is this pull is
doing all right everyone hit no
all right uh i'm voting no
kg
voting no llwc javier
bardem as dr doom with uh the dark
knight rises bane flavor
oh see the thing with javier bardem i
understand why people want javier brown
down because yeah he would be a good
pick
i'm just so you it's like i wouldn't
want to see someone who i'm so used to
saying playing a villain play the
villain
uh play doctor doom but what if they
just do it well
then i will i will gladly
i will gladly adjust and be like you
know what i didn't put up that pole john
put up the pole that's what he does when
he's behind it everyone thinks john's
the nice one here look at him trying to
throw warren under the bus right
so
um basically yeah i just think that i
think javier bardem wouldn't excite me
i i would want it to be something kind
of challenging
like someone who you're like
i don't know
i don't know guys
who would be a
i think people morning's in his biggest
role he was a hero and yes he's old but
something about i think he's too old
or um johan griffith or or something
just so left field like
dj
katrona cool you guys know dj katrona
yeah most people don't know he's in
shazam
poaching is part of the shazamily poach
them
or um
okay yeah we should change the poll or
zane holtz the other guy from the from
dusk till dawn tv show complaint
i want to see quinn and tarantino play
doctor
well then everybody will just die in
that movie zombie x was a joke pick at
first but jeffrey dean morgan as doctor
doom
i'm the doom
i think i think
reid
[Laughter]
oh is that baseball bat here
we don't have it here
right now that's great that's great um
damn we've been at 1.2 k viewers just
like whole time it's [ __ ] amazing
thank you guys i know i told you there's
no news out there so here we are
billy zane good pick uh but i think
jeffrey de morgan could jeffery new
morning and pull it off i would really
like to see jensen ackles in the uh in
the mcu wait i know jen's and knuckles
but i can't picture the face
supernatural
uh the boys the boys the boys
yeah that's why i know he'd be great he
would be a cool wolverine i don't give a
[ __ ] what anyone said snoop dogg is dog
turdu no jensen echoes wolverine would
be great i would love it really yeah i
would love it you have not seen
supernatural or the boys proper have you
no man he'd be amazing yeah dude he's
such a man you don't know anything
warren yeah luke evans not a bad choice
either cinematic goodness oh my god the
biggest super chat of the day
there you go yeah
is that the 50
yeah it is
great
my biggest theory
is that we're still getting tom hardy
tom hall and venom and spider-man
crossover we know that the symbiotes on
earth 616
where holland is
hollandaise and who voices venom we
might even see a variance of eddie brock
also be played by hardy
i'm going to read that again yes john
campy of this oh
my biggest theory
is that we're still getting
it's the key to a john campbell
impression everyone
the [ __ ] my biggest theory the finger
now my biggest theory
on the john campbell show my biggest
theory is my this is where my whole
campion precious
all comes from
my biggest theory
is that we're still getting
that tom hardy
tom hall in venom
and spider-man crossover
we know
the symbiotes
on earth 616
where holland is
and who voices venom
we might even see
a variant
of eddie brock
yeah make sure they behind you know also
be played
by hardy
i still don't understand what this
question is
well you know john when i think of tom
hardy
i think it's still gonna happen
i mean
i don't know where it'll happen i feel
like them putting the symbiote in earth
616 sets up things for secret wars i
feel like the tom hardy venom versus
spider-man is something that probably
has to happen at sony i think it's
definitely gonna i i i
i really feel like
you know it makes more sense to me that
they would do a madame web movie
make like peter parker born in 2002 that
way by the time he's up to like he's in
his 20s
in
by the time like the venom and morbius
movies take place
that way you have a new spider-man to
play him and for their own so that sony
doesn't have to deal with anymore
there's like tom holt [ __ ] by sharing it
yeah yeah
but at the same time
they totally teased us i did with
venom is finally going to fight
spider-man and then i'm just [ __ ]
leaps it was the biggest that's the one
biggest [ __ ] part of all the
spider-man nowhere
it was just like
the venom post-credits scene is we're
like yeah
and then they just [ __ ] like all
right he's gone now
he literally dropped off a piece of poo
was how it went
that's what he did
that's all he did
so
while i think what they're doing madame
webb actually is like well that sounds
like your best way to not run into what
you ran into with no way home
however um
i think they got to make it happen they
got to make tom hardy and tom holland
fight i hate the fact that we
that they didn't do it
i get what he's saying in the stupid
coy's in the chat quad koi's in the chat
koi zhan
coy am i not koi is it the real koi
you're not coy no no you talk too slow
oh
you're a koi on benadryl that's the way
you are
where'd he go i saw koi's name
everyone find koi
he's just i found cole hi cole oh that's
good enough
we don't need a coal
well it's too late now secret's out what
does coijandro mean by that
oh there he is
what secret are they talking about greg
is wait where'd it go
coy greg is mad at me for spoiling all
of she-hulk episode 4 so he replaced me
you didn't say you had free time today
this is my only way to hang out with
warren it's true i won't hang out with
him unless we do a live stream there
goes koi having to make everything about
him that's right coy
coy center
cinematic goodness i appreciate that
super chat and hopefully what's warren's
poll
warren's poll ended and uh 61 percent of
people said yes 26 are gonna wait till
the end to decide
and 12
think that no you're not doing it
guess what we're on to a new poll now
though i don't care um all right let's
see here
all right
let's move on is the cinematic goodness
the end of it uh for right now but let's
do a little refresher hold on go back
i'm gonna choose uh for a little bit
i'll get you choose pikachu
why is she oh zachary quinto as doom
would be good i i like this
snoop dogg snoop dogg is doom dog turd
[Laughter]
two g's perfect it's easy
he's got the green you know cloak and
everything you can put some weed leaves
on it you know i wanted to say
v-i-c-d-double-o
fantastic that [ __ ]
exactly
i think uh norman reedus would probably
be the it's either a normal radius or a
keanu for ghost rider either one oh yeah
they're both perfect picks and they're
both different they'd both be perfect
see norman everybody says norman reedus
and i don't know if i could lose him
into that
really i would be rooting for him but i
feel like i would be somewhat distracted
by daryl dixon because it's so close
motorcycle guy you know leather
i feel like i'd be more aware of keanu
reeves
but the difference is i don't actually
expect that to happen
so i mean they've already said they've
met with them a bunch they're just
waiting for the right role
as well the multiverse is just gonna
bring john wick in i mean
i mean i think they gotta have at least
one movie where they do all the fanfic
ones the ones where you're not actually
gonna get everyone to commit what what
if
the fans
[Laughter]
what if we listen to you all actually we
want nova i'm seeing people talking
about nova in here i mean it's announced
yes kind of it's announced from
the hollywood reporter of writers do you
think do you think nova uh is gonna be a
movie or a show oh a movie for sure it's
a chevy i mean
i don't work for marvel
which would you imagine it'll be a movie
yes i do all right good to know yeah you
don't work for marvel no uh
get on the get on board buddy well
that's why he doesn't
i get it now
he doesn't get checked from feige
because he works directly for him yeah
no he's like he doesn't have to pay him
off because he's on the payroll already
where's coy did he take my narcissistic
joke seriously
i was only eighty percent serious
i would be a great doctor doom i think
doctor dude needs to have a lot of
sarcasm
and you can't always be serious
i saw somebody call out for jason
statham as the silver surfer
is captain marvel still becoming the new
avengers leader i hope so
i think everyone would be very happy
yeah everyone would be really stoked
about that really stoked about i
actually like captain marvel's
scene and miss in the miss marvel post
credits and i watched the um the the
disney world ride what was that thing
the
one with the ant-man talking about you
know going up the anus [ __ ] no no
wasn't that the
like on the cruise or something the
cruise yeah yeah and her personality
there i think what they've done uh i
think they are totally reinventing
captain marvel they should they
and also it's like i feel like they
didn't really have a proper direction
for her and her performance makes sense
to me in the first one because she's
like i am alien but i'm not alien what
am i but now she's more man of steel
actually more terms exactly she's more
at terms with who she is now and i feel
like now she can really find her actual
personality so
yeah i think um i don't think she's
gonna be the leader of the avengers but
you know people were out to like take
her down before
anything johnny depp is doom i don't
know about that no no no no brandon
ralph is read
coy wasn't at his new rockstars live
stream isn't his ankle monitor working
his own house arrested until further
notice that's funny
oh do we got a stream lab jaime hamilton
stream lab
we need better sound effects
we gotta create sound effects yeah yeah
leave some sounds you want to hear and
we'll work on getting some new sounds in
this in this piece what's the poll right
now will robert downey jr return for
secret wars 42 percent are on your side
no
look yeah 30 i said 42 on your side that
you said no
actual math no because you have to add
this yes but as a start
yeah cause that's still yes all right
yes but as tom cru i think he's gonna
come back as tom cruise yes robert
downey junior is dancing guys
joel mayberry uh netflix trailer
department um pisses me off oh no i i've
said it many times
i've seen it happen time and time again
i run experiments i'm like
netflix is always copyright claiming us
instantly yeah and then we'll dispute it
and they let it go when the videos are
done getting views
every time and i've talked with many
people many other people do reactions
and i'll go were you claimed by netflix
no
and after that i'm like you guys are a
bunch of [ __ ] they're like they're
easy to work with on actually covering
their shows like when we react to their
shows but the trailer department i don't
know what they have uh why they have it
out for us when i'm like i don't get why
you let us cover your shows but not your
[ __ ] huge it's me it is you you're
working netflix
[ __ ] feige
i have a little bit of weird faith in um
and uh
in a craven i do i do oh what's jamie
hamilton saying hey
do you think dreamwalking could be
brought back up as a plan to defeat kang
especially it's like a freddy cougar
situation especially
just grab him
wake up
especially since strange has a
photographic memory
also hope debran wohl and eldon henson
reprise their roles in daredevil born
again thanks to you all
uh
dream walking i never thought about that
dreamwalking as an element to fight kang
that could be cool
jump into your other selves
oh that would be a gnarly ass like
secret wars movie and everybody's just
like sacrificing their varying bodies
like if you had tons of people dream
walking like the amount of universes
being pulled together and incurring on
each other would be huge but i feel like
only wanda could not only a few people
could dream why not everyone could dream
walk
yeah you would have had to a whole
universe of mary sue well
was the question directly about doctor
strange
um
oh yes especially since strange's
photographic memory it was about uh uh
so like he could maybe teach people i
think you have to be very skilled in
some type of magic to be able to do that
in the first place
like
could professor x stream walk you know
what i mean or does there have to be
like that magical component and
understanding like it's it's not a bad
it's not a bad uh it's not a bad theory
it's not a bad theory i actually really
like it i don't think it's gonna come
back up though in all honesty
i feel like it's gonna come to play in
some way
i mean i think we'll mention it but
right ryanair is in the chat
uh oh where is he at
where's screencrest where is it under
the screen crash name where
where everyone
are you guys lying you guys [ __ ] lied
at me you guys had me fooled you this
way to troll me isn't this
he just [ __ ] i don't see it
[Laughter]
find him now now i'm pissed
would it be under screen crush sniper
says that only sorcerers can dream walks
okay okay okay well that's what i mean
yeah
so
ooh
john
i don't see ryan yeah you can put those
away for right now while i refresh
the
supers
all right machine gun kelly is doctor
doom ooh
you find out he's just some hack variant
like the first the first mandarin and
then eminem comes in
do you hear the game where the game
released a 10-minute m m diss track yeah
i know the game's going after eminem and
eminem's gonna like talk about [ __ ]
on the toilet or whatever he does now
a lot of poop uh similes in those bars
now yeah oh damn we got a super suit
also rick alts says bill nye for doctor
doom do you mean the science guy bill
nye or do you mean bill nye the the
other guy who's like in sean of the dead
and davey jones because he could be like
he's too old now but he could be like a
cool dog i think obviously it's bill nye
the science guy is dream walking
possible without the darkhold
that's a good question
chat
is dreamworks the chat is happening chad
is asking
oh good question
because yeah they wouldn't i think
wanda couldn't do it after it was
destroyed that's true yeah she couldn't
do it are you sure about that oh
well she hey enchantrex what's up
who's enchantrex um she is on my channel
a lot and we talking discord too because
she is awesome warren don't hit on your
fans she has a boyfriend
a warren could anticipate my next
statement he's not in the chat now
he owns a gun
i have seen it
um
well no because the whole part of going
to wondergore mountain
was because the darkhold was gone
but but i thought she did dream oh yes
but
that wasn't the real dark hole that was
first destroyed and then they went to
one decor mountain
yeah yeah that's right yeah right yeah
so i think they do need it
i remembering sorry did you guys watch
better call saul last night don't ruin
it for john in the chat this details
don't ruin the specifics
but it's so good i'm gonna do it
dude better call saul was amazing
i still haven't a moment of silence
i was about to say what i haven't seen
yet and i don't want to bring it up
because i don't want people to ruin it
for me
reactions
uh all right robbie brown
youtube do that now what oh yeah
it makes itself a desktop widget yeah
that's youtube that's new yeah it's
awesome isn't it yeah that's a good app
yeah we're still 1.1 people here that's
amazing you're welcome people say end
strong i wait till we're out it is all
worn
[Laughter]
i wait i wait till we're at 100 people
yeah i don't like to go out strong we
never changed the title
i guess tom cruise was iron man we
talked about some of it you know
[Laughter]
i thought it would be all about it i bet
the whole chat was gonna be cast the
x-men and i'm like i guess not john
stamos is dr doom i'm here we've talked
about upcoming characters this whole
time george cliff somebody robo tech
jenner mentions george clooney as dr
doom and somebody else said that earlier
but with nipples
doom nips in like metal yeah
breast plate you know something like
that exactly
hammering down those nips
vibranium nips yeah we haven't seen the
sandman like honestly i've been i've
been doing the movie reactions so i've
been making more time for those you know
and like the shows that we do commit to
where we're being more selective about
the shows that we really want to commit
to
so that's why we didn't do sandman
man
we heard it wasn't that and i was like
that's disappointing yeah if it's not
about that neil
robbie brown uh thank you robbie sorry
guys gotta get back to work but how to
get my f forecasting dev patel is mr
fantastic ooh i love that actually
that's the solid pit that's actually
pretty solid micah monroe as sue i have
no idea who that is i'm showing you her
right now
she's uh she's my girl that i put oh
she's from yeah
it follows girl that's who i said oh
yeah
actually i don't i is that a common i
was i was just
that that was off the top of my head
michael monroe and i i i haven't heard
people cast her but that is a
a genuine interest of mine
she's a genuine interesting
that's a genuine answer
to an answer uh rudy pankow as torch i
don't know who rudy pankow is i'm
pouring up a photo
oh i've seen this guy before oh yes
where have i seen him
he's got muscles it looks like
reminds me harry styles hey a little bit
oh my god look at those abs
i've seen him before too but i can't
figure out where i've definitely seen
those abs before
[Laughter]
[Music]
has been you got some uh not as
common names oh
jack reacher guy yeah yeah look you
there why would you want to hide that
body and never go back no just just him
like that yeah just have him be that and
just kind of put a mask
i've heard amazing things about that
jack reacher show
yeah no i've heard it's really good
it'll make you want to never go back to
the movies with tom cruise right
that also gave us jai courtney in his
one palatable role that isn't captain
boomerang
you know what i noticed when we saw uh
top gun maverick and amc they did not
run that nicole kidman commercial i know
it's such [ __ ] but so why do you
think they didn't do it because tom
cruise probably requested that they
don't put his ex-wife right in front of
his movie
i am not purposely making things awkward
jeffrey
i that's called comedy it's called
that's just how i the only way i know
how to be
um let's see here oh let's keep going
yes oh my god something about galactus
this is you you're all about galactus
fishman
i am very excited to see sorry for
touching you guys couldn't see this
see this is that that's how you don't
get canceled what we need on this on
this sound board is one of those is one
of those sounds where people absolutely
you know the crowd is reacting to like
some scandal i'm very excited says
fishman i do like galactus great to see
kang and doom in the new avengers movie
but saying that do you guys believe they
might introduce or hint at galactus at
the end of the vendor secret wars i keep
up the hard work i would love that
um i think i did a video
recently about how i think phase
seven yes you said how phase seven was
gonna blow our minds that's yes i think
that is the galactus saga i don't know
if that's what i'll actually call it do
you think galactus is worse than um
kang and doom
king at his core
is just like a very advanced
human that's very like that's an
oversimplification but
he's he is a human right right you know
what i'm saying um
like nathaniel richards is born in the
future
where time travels actually banned
but gets us the hands-on you know time
travel machine goes back in time goes
all over time and you know just like we
saw in loki he can kind of see
everything which is one reason he gets
so powerful
and
galactus is just this huge cosmic entity
with uh
the power cosmic and just you know what
i mean it's like he's so
big just just big like it's such a he's
such a big classic idea with
yeah like you know that guy is like
squatting all day every day
just getting it
big
someone says brennan fraser is the thing
i said i could sit john on fire
yeah for those who suggested you as the
human torch that'll work i mean we could
try to work do you wanna i'm just gonna
join the human torch for three minutes
i will miss him
and the memorium starts right now
i i hope they tease maybe in secret wars
but they didn't really tease anything
after infinity war just that little
hammer clink which is just a call back
to iron man so i don't know if they
would tease it but i i really hope
that's next and i feel like that's next
oh uh someone chat
saying fan cast gambit you know who i
think would be a good gambit
um i actually i think it would be cool
to bring channing tatum back yeah but he
was devastated who was the guy
you only saw the first season of troop
what
yes
who's the cajun guy in that oh yeah yeah
renee i don't know that actor's name he
did he was a good uh yeah he did a
really good game he did an amazing case
he made me want to learn that actually
yeah he did an amazing cajun accent yeah
only for that purpose too i think you
should play gamut he looks nothing like
gambit
seriously would not be a good pick
overall the accent but he could do the
voice
to have him dub
um channing tatum
yes there you go
i want vincent cassell his gambit
oh my god it's warning someone
discovered to see you oh hey dashie what
charlie hunnamus century
do you know who sentry is
yeah we talked about that henry cavill
yeah yeah i wasn't paying attention to
what you were saying i was too focused
on thanks
you're talking about evil superman yeah
yeah that's true but no i think a golac
who would be a good galactus austin
butler for gambit awesome austin butler
would be a great gambit yeah that would
be a fantastic gambit did you see elvis
oh this yeah did you see elvis not yet
did i see elvis excited to see it i did
vlog thank you very much
that's not gonna be that's gonna be the
most impossible reaction
i was watching elvis and like when those
women were losing their [ __ ] over him
and moving his hips i was like that was
[ __ ] ridiculous and i looked it up
i'm like holy god this was real oh dude
yeah like really the sexual repression
was through the roof he has hips that's
all you had to do back then i'm being
called to notice that this man has hips
what would you do if you had a time
machine i'd go back in time and move my
hips and just get all the women in the
world
yeah man
go have some crazy videos start vanilla
elvis sex
like you could be a crazy homeless guy
just standing in the street moving your
hips like go have sex with chuck oh my
god
but austin butler would be a great
gambit he would embody that role it
would be
it'd be awful it would be a girletto
situation
i've always liked the idea throwing
cards at everyone on set
oh yes that'd be a good call
i eat planets
[Laughter]
i have a very particular set of hunger
christopher walken has
[Laughter]
moment of silence play that moment of
silence
cricket
cricket silence silence
the international sound of silence
and bob's burgers follow up
a moment of loudness will we ever get a
black order backstory assembly
probably not
dude no
movie we've moved on whole movie
dedicated to the black order let's do it
i want squidward's spin-off hey
sink field hoops we are no cowards like
jaby kawaii
we're keeping this live on the channel
kevin spacey has doctor doom most
definitely
fireside chat we should have a way to
like hit a button that allows us to just
bring the the the regular chat on screen
invent that
i might be able to free up that right
now to see what we could do you have
more fun here than when you're streaming
with chris
why would you ask me that because we're
live and i wanna
answer and i hope he's watching in
florida with his wife
yeah
what is the what is the what is the
uh it's different
i'll tell you let's bring it back to
friends when ross sleeps with the girl
yeah how was it he's like it was
[ __ ] [ __ ]
anus we were on a break were they on a
break greg
uh i i think they were honored i think
they're unbreakable i mean they were in
a break but i still think it was too
soon you don't just go and bang right
away you would say
that's how you know the break is real
when you're banging
yeah
but mark was at her house
the fight lives on people we're never
letting it go nova win i think phase six
i think they're gonna announce it at d23
do you think keanu will play a good
doctor doom
no
i feel like he's too
what's how do i explain this i'm from
that very uh yeah like he's not
like not upbeat enough
right
like i don't know if that's the right
word i mean yeah that's why tarantino's
got to play him
oh hey i've seen a couple people talking
about this red man's land in the chat
says recast sam elliott as thunderbolt
ross he's getting up there in age won't
matter if he stays the red hulk all the
time
i've heard also people say ed harris
oh my god hey john you did it you
invented it yeah
john invented he invented technology wow
wow you should be
is quiet phone ring no my phone's right
there i just i think i just felt a weird
static in my leg can you guys hit the
like button if you're here it was worn
all right
so um yeah look at this chaos on screen
yes i like it it's we feed on chaos
let's take a look aquarius 69
i know it's a lot thank you jacquarius
oh that was pretty great i know it's a
long shot do you think marvel would
introduce wolverine a hulk vs wolverine
movie then have bruce lose it
lose it and lead to world war hulk
oh that would be gnarly i would love oh
how are you feeling warren i know this
is longer than you normally stream oh
i'm good you're good you're having fun
sure you sure
yes it's a blast happy to be here john i
put down in the chat that they're what
the next i said what should be the next
poll so keep a lookout okay
i'll ask i'll answer the question i've
always wanted to see a hulk versus
wolverine movie i thought it would be
great if you could do like a guillermo
del toro directed hulk versus wolverine
and you actually got like a massive dude
and put him in like it had to be alt
universe i don't think it would be like
a an actual mcu yeah yeah like because
if you did like a hard r hulk versus
wolverine like like wolverine fresh out
of weapon x or some [ __ ] or mind control
weapon like if you just made wolverine
like the villain yeah yeah
yeah yeah wolverine on the hunt for him
and but hulk like
oh you can make it like a really hard r
with a very violent uh i really want
this so hard it would be cool man it'd
be like with practical effects and [ __ ]
yeah and like a very scary wolverine and
a scary hulk
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that would be
that's what i envision when i think of
that yeah cause because
a year and a half ago two years ago
mark ruffalo was at some con or like
something he was on a panel yeah and he
was talking about future ideas for the
hulk and he said he has a lot and he
actually said hulk first wolverine and
everyone's like
that would be amazing who wouldn't want
to [ __ ] see that i want to see that
imagine that title review but it would
have to be it can't be smart hulk
no no no you got to bring like hulk to
like a rageful guy
but i do like the idea of like an
introduction of like that can you
imagine that d23 and we got a different
hulk movie coming out hulk versus
wolverine and then somehow that but it
just sounds like if i were to read that
on an mcu timeline it would be uh yeah
they fight at first but then they team
up for some bigger bat and i'm like i
don't want that i want to see i want to
see one of them lose right right yeah
that's kind of the issue with these
team-up films too yeah or the versus
films i mean
dan trachtenberg directing the wolverine
film is a great call great call
um let's see here
in the chat uh somebody asked well now
you can just highlight it john oh looky
there that's why i said we should have
it on screen all right even though on
the phone when you look at it
it's so tiny you can't really see it
yeah uh uh uh somebody says first off
cornworld hello to sweden uh fan cast
for squirrel girl i say melania vintrub
or kate micucci but that's just me
anyway to [ __ ]
moment of silence
i think
squirrel girl could be played by oh my
god that is milan of intro what the [ __ ]
i think squirrel girl could be played by
um that girl from it
oh sophia lillis yeah
or sadie sink
okay or millie bobby brown google
literally
see there oh it's a podcast and she's
already in that okay well they already
stole my casting for their squirrel
podcast but yeah nah sophia lillis i can
see that
all right guys we should actually wrap
up this stream pretty soon
i thought this was it we're just gonna
always
thought this was the life this is life
now
and then we'd like rotate john would go
out sleep and we just yeah one of us has
to do the night shift
i'm not seeing your new pole here bud
i know i said that what should be the
next poll
i said what should be the next poll okay
gotcha
that'll be the poll scroll down a tiny
bit
apparently i'm messed up
that's the most stuffed up i know jake i
know
oh what role should be given to dwayne
johnson none he would try to control it
and he'd be like
no i shouldn't appear in here write me
out of it if you if we ever do a
a
mcu movie in the jungle
yeah just have him in there as himself
not even like an mcu character just like
he's walking in the background and by
the way i think um
i think uh
uh what dwayne johnson
did you read about that with the black
adam shazam thing
yeah he he specifically had uh didn't
want shazam in the film right he won
black adam in the shazam sorry yeah
opposite yeah i think
what people have totally just read a
headline and took that out of proportion
if you read the actual article it's
actually really good reasoning uh he he
thought that it would be a disservice
because they're both so tonally
different and they would be more
rewarding in the long run if they both
had solo adventures and then you had
them fight each other yeah and i'm like
yeah that's a
that's perfect
but everyone was like the rocks trying
to control
the dancing
why would you say i'm not fight black
adam in his first movie
i mean it
it's like 10 plus years in the making i
mean the rock's been patient about it
yes yeah that's a good point too yeah
it's been 10 years man so i mean how
much are you really
trying to control hey it's clancy you
will actually see all of us in two days
clancy oh we're gonna meet clancy hey
i'm sorry you are i've met her uh yeah
that'd be weird if you hadn't married
but yeah we're gonna meet clancy yeah
warren says amazing things about you
he says that you are uh i'm not gonna
make any jokes i'm gonna actually see
you
there's a risk
[Laughter]
cage for a cameo i really do think
they should get nick cage in secret wars
they should not not
robert downey jr no no he's got to play
all his characters from the empirical
way to massachusetts he's got to do his
filmography of characters
massive marvel's name when he like yells
at his name
nicholas cage i haven't seen the movie
yet oh my god
no i haven't seen it come on neither of
us rebel wilson would be a great thing
[Laughter]
what did she
i would be
oh no
she'll have to bulk up
gabe we ready we read your super did we
read your super chat game gabe i thought
we read that one did we not
well it's either that we haven't read it
yet or we did i could have sworn we read
gabe's
oh man we got something to get through
all right guys gabe you're you're you're
still listening we're gonna turn off
refresh that john and then turn them on
we're gonna turn off the super chats
because we got
i gotta eat something yeah who needs to
eat you're hungry too yeah
yeah listen gonna have to go to best buy
at five o'clock
la traffic dude let's
an hour
go get there like an hour man
you listen to some tunes red hot chili
peppers man oh do you like children i
love the chili peppers hot chili peppers
live
so did i
yeah not when greg did though i saw i
saw them very recently live it was
magical
they were like give it away give it away
give it away now
wait so they performed their songs did
they give it away they didn't they gave
all their games away full show away from
they give the whole show away for free
okay
god john i can't fill the silence right
now oh enjoy the silence depeche mode
you have buttons you can fill this oh my
god is christian harloff messaging me
right now i know he was on campia this
morning was he what a dick
yeah talking up all that she-hulk love
uh-oh look out
craws
can i have one of your guys chairs
i'll give you five bucks to crisp high
five
these chairs uh sure if you want one
come over here bring it bring that link
and bring that hotly are you still
sponsored by these chair people
sure are you still an and a seat partner
because can i be honest about these
chairs
they just gave me the chairs can i be
honest about the chat they're not like
sponsored please speak your truth i
don't like sitting in those chairs
that's why you don't really see me
sitting in there i like the iron man one
which is the one i use every day but
these two are
not the best
wow i'm not sponsored by them i did one
thing for them
did you get i'm sorry i just looked at
warren's phone sorry are you gonna call
yourself there
i missed a call
um did you guys see our reaction to high
tops films video who should flea play in
the mcu
oh um people are saying flea is
wolverine
but he has to be naked just dude the red
hot chili peppers would make a great
fantastic four you have john frusciante
sue storm then chad is like clearly a
huge guy he can be thing
and then anthony kiedis has to be mr
fantastic and then a flea
is uh the human torch
that's a great call man dude
uh but no you don't want to have these
chairs trust me not even for five
dollars but oh my god christian harloff
i just saw that you texted me i was just
talking about how you texted me
christian the loft um yeah we can do
friday our lawful i'm texting you right
now
friday
what is your polling you have going on
here
ah of course yes that is the clear
answer
it's the only objective truth the whole
situation sorry sorry okay i'm uh we
gotta focus okay we're on we're in the
end game now here on this live stream
off i'm gonna get super focused you turn
them off we turned off the super chats
watch this we're gonna rock this guys
off all right dominic webb cousin of
mark webb
do you think we will see bounty hunters
in the mcu
warren you think we'll see some bounty
hunters yeah
wow way to give some substantial
feedback there i answered the question
you asked me a question and i answered
it
yes i'm not familiar with bounty hunters
within marvel
well i i guess i have to ask were you
talking about general bounty hunters
well i i was going to say are you
talking to me about the mandalorian
i know what boundaries i know they're
both disney like
d he's no there's a i guess there's a is
there a run here for marvel bounty
hunters there's a category marvel
database bounty hunters but it's like
[ __ ] like felicia hardy and jennifer
walters well there are people
who let's do it bounty hunted things
like like technically like deadpool has
you know like they're saying like
characters that become bounty hunters
yeah yeah yeah yeah um i thought they
were like a bounty hunter
familiar with it well i also didn't know
if it was like
an actual question about like
mandalorian bounty hunters like in
secret wars or something because any
universal thing is possible they're both
disney
uh
but um when that day comes
or if you're asking if there's going to
be kind of like a story that is kind of
like a mandalorian bounty hunter type of
thing because that would actually
kind of be cool i think i think it would
be a really rad sound yeah that would be
really good the bounty hunter too
who amber mid thunder is x23 that would
be great they can get the oh if they can
get her oh i love that she's amazing i
disagree amber mid thunder
from prince
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah she's so
cool and she's got some marvel cred from
uh legion which i have not seen
oh legion yeah but yeah people like
legion legion dan stevens great guy
care chef amp oh okay we got you
wolverine casting dylan o'brien cool
tokyo jetson cool name
big fan guys i've been thinking the mcu
has become less adult oriented compared
to earlier phases it's been 15 years
people that grew up with it are adults
now and some of us were already grown i
don't know maybe i'm wrong uh you know
tokyo first of all appreciate the super
chat
secondly uh yeah i don't think you're
wrong i i that is something that kind of
did dawn on me is
other than you get like the occasional
it depends sometimes it seems
it's where you get like a real in
between like thor 11 thunder at times
felt a little in between to me it's like
a lot of people had like more of the
child well the orgy part it's not
exactly meant for kids no no orgy part
of the dark black and white planet and
like that stuff was real like uh adult
heavy but then there's a lot of the time
um it it uh
then you got stuff like she hulk and
miss marvel which feel more kid-oriented
then you got a moon knight which is
worse
i think for the i think some of the
adult humor
goes over it might go over the kids
heads because there are some adults you
haven't seen the
three and four but is it oh yeah i
haven't seen it before yeah the those
first two felt like extremely
family-friendly the first one's very
family friendly second one too i would
say yeah
gosh they all blend together
because when i watched them they didn't
like well yeah they didn't separate they
didn't tell me what was what
they all yeah it was like a movie almost
but i it depends you know like sometimes
it does seem to go very mature i think
moon night like their fifth episode
especially was so adult yeah that's not
a kid's episode at all see to me it
feels like the first i mean it's an
oversimplification but i feel like we're
in the teenage years of marvel now where
you know we're starting to get a little
more rambunctious starting to use a
little more language starting to
acknowledge sexuality a little bit more
it's it's funny like to me growing up i
always associated the level of violence
in action we got all throughout the
first phase
uh and the first
saga i should say the first three phases
is being kind of like kid-accessible
pg-13 but uh but now i feel like
thematically they're trying to branch
out into like every character needs
therapy
i've heard people say that phase four is
the therapy stage where everyone's like
i got so much internal struggle
well also the
the violence in doctor strange
multiverse the madness and the horror is
not not kid friendly and that was one
that was like a lot of people were like
this is the first
marvel movie i'm not taking my kids to
yeah i heard that a lot i saw kids
scared in in the theaters when i when we
saw it on imax people were scared
there's some freaky stuff in it and
she's like
when they when she kills the illuminati
and then she pisses on their faces yeah
that was crazy for me it was like too
much too much
oh good
all right guys whoa
come on bronson plays thank you bronson
please
you're doing great greg you're doing
great
dj do you think you're dj
no okay good hey bring your brats please
hey
on two other live streams you said you
could react to our daredevil fan films
on youtube
thank you so much for everything in the
link pull it up right now
all right
hold on
[Laughter]
pull it up right now bronson plays you
can clip this out yeah yeah just just
send the link into the thing otherwise
it'll take me a minute show them our
login password make sure you show the
password do you allow links
what do you allow links in your chat
what do you mean specifically not allow
the links
let's see
hold on
we're going to pull this up we are going
in the meantime john while you're
looking for this can you also do your
galactic in your nick offerman
impression
as galactus
i have traveled across many worlds to
devour your planet
all right
sorry i was mildly distracted what's
your instagram and i'm gonna do this
we're gonna do this i swear
bronson plays
come on
all right i'm just going to find it find
it johnson
find it john i'm so finding it right now
we got no time
got no time no nothing i wish i could
more effectively search the inbox but i
can't cause instagram isn't designed to
be used on a desktop even though it's
really
that way you're really failing us right
now
guys whoever's here can you hit the like
button
can you come up with a better title for
our video yeah
greg sucks at titles
wait i don't ever call him and ask for
help with titles never that doesn't that
doesn't happen i just say warren just
put the word leak in there
avengers full plot leaked
avengers 8 full plot
we're not done with the with the super
chats we're just looking for a very
specific one right now
how's about this damn who are these
girls you're replying to on our
instagram dang john
josh they're all unopened john's only
just talking to the girls they're the
holidays full of [ __ ] oh my god look at
john just like i love how the screen is
like this big but instagram is wow
i just can't stop talking to the women
hey look it's paul
paul from heavy
screen crush heavy screen crush yes john
you're gonna find it i promise yup
it's not our motto partners nope nope
you're doing great you're doing good so
good john find that link what are we
actually doing uh he's looking for a
link uh to someone who we uh
yeah but apparently we promised
you know i'm sure there's an easier way
to find this
what is the super chat you know bronson
plays
i gotcha title were they on a break or
not marvel discussion with cosmic wonder
that's it changing now bronson plays
with the zed at the end
change it now why aren't we changing
okay so i found you what is it what is
it bronson plays with they're on a
breaker now the real wonderful no hosts
yet
[Music]
this is the best part for you guys
all right what we're gonna do is we're
gonna hunt this down and then the next
live stream we are reacting to it
regardless the second you come in here
we're reacting to it
because we gotta we're short on time
right now
yeah we already committed 18 hours here
we've been here for days
84 years
warren's got to go
he's got a hot date tonight
yeah sorry bronson plays next live
stream
next live stream
unless it showed up in the chat already
we're still at 900 in the chat it's not
my date they're on a date with each
other i'm just showing up to crash it
i'm sorry bronson plays we're gonna find
this
show us the [ __ ] well i'm reacting to
it on my channel
mike 2021
no no no don't do that don't do that
what's happening mark strong as dr doom
is perfect just see his performance in
robin hood across russell crowe i think
mark strong would be a solid doctor doom
he has the perfect look you know mark
strong of course i'm trying to i'm
trying to picture it what do you need to
wig
the doctor do you need hair
i mean nah might still watch you still
see victor von doom especially
did they just announce nova as a series
what
and i really worry a thing no no yeah
yeah all right but no i think mark
strong would be a really solid doctor
doom
i think he i think in terms of the
acting chops yeah and if he has to wear
a wig he could read it we could wear a
wig impossible i love how wicked zombie
was just like we don't acknowledge the
chat this is [ __ ] do you have no idea
how often we've been talking with the
chat they always say that every time
there's always someone who thinks we're
gonna talk to the chat you're neglecting
your fans
i appreciate your supporters
come on you see that we're actually
interacting with the chat the entire
time yeah yeah
we even got the chat up on screen we do
and our phones
ooh okay but thank you mike's colin
thanks colin
nikolai costan costner waldo as a doctor
doom
who's that he was jamie lannister in
game of thrones oh
actually out of everyone mentioned today
he's my personal favorite like so see do
you know who that is have you seen game
of thrones it's okay if you haven't worn
you have to have seen everything you're
too busy man
i'll show you a photo you just want to
always talk for me or yeah yeah okay but
you've seen it i'll let you know i mean
have i i don't know you
look here he is from a prison movie
i know who he is
dragged across concrete
or no cell block 99.
he'd be a good doctor doom wouldn't he
he would a little handsome he actually
would so good but doctor doom's supposed
to be handsome no he's supposed to be
horrendous yeah but also handsome no no
he's actually supposed to be handsome
he he would get so extreme that and one
of the or like the way kirby envisioned
it
was that he had like one main little
scar that he thought ruined his face and
that's why he wore a mask did you say
kirby not just jack kirby yeah yeah i
know kurt i call him kirby curb
sometimes i say uh kerbinator kerbinator
yeah
i call him jackoff uh and i just said
like we got nicknames for each other
so what's yours
um so yeah
but i think i think nikolai costner
would be yeah koster waldo would be a
perfect uh perfect choice too sink field
i think for me it would be good
yeah because he he he i think he could
bring a decent amount of like genuine
humanity they all could they're all good
picks everyone has picked solid picks
except for greg except for greg i but i
do think sean william scott would be the
perfect one yeah bring him back williams
he hasn't done anything in a while yeah
hoops
jimmy campbell bower who's that i know
that name
guys
oh my god he's the guy from uh sweeney
todd harry potter harry
potter things
city of yeah
as the beyonder who's the beyonder
warren
the beyonder is actually who dr doom
um
he takes his powers
to get become god emperor doom you know
i keep trying to set up warren to fail
actually wait
oh now you got to google it is it or is
it the one above all i'm going to tell
you who the beyonder is right now just
off the top
yeah it is to be honored no it is yeah
yeah he was you know he at one point was
considered to be the most powerful being
is that what computer says it's not
wikipedia that's not a marvel database
that's not wiki facts that's greg's
opinion that's who so doctor doom takes
his power and becomes god in purdue
instagram oh my god
cool and secret wars 2 you mean electric
secret lou
it's just chas
i can't wait to eat but would jamie
campbell be a good beyonder
i think jamie campbell could do anything
as long as his villainous and it
requires a pretty looking person i just
i'm not intimidated
why have you seen stranger things yes
the fourth season
i'm not intimidated in all those scenes
he's not in from seasons one twilight
harry potter like all these that's all i
see in that hey man you'd be great you
don't know what you're talking about
since scary as batman he can anybody
from twilight can can thrive
all right it's just chas since disney
owns dragon ball rights imagine seeing
goku in secret wars that would not be
distracting at all that would only be
cool and awesome disney owns dragon ball
rats
i guess i didn't know that
uh
i i think uh goku showing up in secret
wars would definitely that should be the
new poll before we go
justin chatwin bring him in kanye west
says the beyonder
i think kanye west should be professor x
i i think that dragon ball z movie was
the biggest letdown in my life
no
we should you still see it saw the same
movie
dude that's the one for like 15 years
ago i think it's underrated
i think it's garbage no i think it's
very underrated i just put out a video
recently about unpopular opinions and
and and i forgot to mention that my top
pick
would have been dragon ball z
is an underrated film and they knew
exactly what they were doing it was all
intentional the live action one yeah
yeah with white goku with the japanese
grandfather yeah
i think that one really making a good
point i think that was
that was a good one
i i granted i only saw it one time like
15 years ago whenever it came out but i
don't think disney's going to ruin
dragon ball z
i think they're going to make it even
better
than it ever has
yes it's going to be good
it's going to be the best version it's
going to be the best donald trump is
doom i love it i'm the best i'm the best
uh dictator we're gonna get the best
vibranium
ask anyone to tell you
i made the best world out of all the
remaining universes greatest it's gonna
go up against kang wrong
kang you're wrong
uh ask anybody ask anybody they'll tell
you
cameron scott
do you think a doom character movie
would be a cool solo movie yes 100
especially if you there's so many doom
storms that could be marvel's joker just
make a doom solo movie i think it
creates so much more interesting stakes
if you have a solo film first um because
like with wanda getting to know her
intimately in wanda vision and then
seeing her as the villain just made it
so much more compelling in doctor
strange so
imagine if one of your main big baddies
it gets their own solo movie first and
then suddenly they're the big baddie you
would just the the emotional investment
makes for a much more interesting
complexity so yeah i i would love love
to see uh like a solo doom movie first
like i would actually like that as well
i'd like to see him like kind of good
and then kind of like you said like
become the villain see from the
protagonist's perspective yeah uh that
would be awesome real quick alex c
loses spooky's coverage will probably
not happen but that shows great and i
hope they keep making it
thank you for coming to my ted talk
now that's what we're doing i don't know
what the [ __ ] he's talking about lois is
spooky's is a great show on hbo all
right
sam and uh julio torres i mean barry
should be
oh that's the show on hbo yeah my bad
barry's a good show yeah i'm going to
watch barry
brian on seals
brian o'neill singleton took me a sec
aaron eckhart as victor vandum inside
joke will be that everyone pronounces it
doom party on rejects
why is that the anti-joke
uh is that the wrong pronunciation
he'll be like it's frankenstein
i don't get the joke victor
instead of doom
wait are we pronouncing victor von doom
wrong this whole time
well no but if the original spelling is
that dohm then it would be more like dom
this is a fascinating comment yeah
if you really made his name be accurate
to how like eastern european languages
work
we're going to camp you this and move on
uh thank you brian
it would be it would be a good that
would be good and we appreciate your
support
good running joke i think i see where
you're coming from because he wouldn't
want to be called doom but then
eventually he's going to embrace it sink
field hoops is back thank you so much
thank you sing feel hoops if you think
doom will be the villain of secret wars
do you think we'll have enough time to
build him up and develop him enough
if he is introduced in the post credits
of black panther kind of forever yes
yeah i think doom could be like
implemented throughout
kind of like thano how thanos was
thanos yeah yeah but hopefully a little
bit more
i mean this is like thanos was barely
like
you would get like hints by
the
something like uh
what the [ __ ] her name nebula right
understanding like oh neville's got a
[ __ ] up dad her dad was thanos oh my
god nebula and gamora their relationship
knowing who their dad was and hearing
little bits and pieces throughout
helped build up thanos that by the time
you got to infinity war you would have
the intimidation then you could humanize
them more so yeah i think i think
there's a very solid version of how you
can do it i mean secret wars is
three years from now
we have time
yeah they've got like 46 properties
coming out
so
yeah
thank you bridal singleton ellie's money
you got it
good appreciate it glad to hear that
sing feel hoops
yep we did him alex williams
do you guys think marvel casts top
actors as lesser characters and unknown
actors as top characters
oh i never looked at it that way but
there does seem to be a bit of a pattern
huh is that accurate
let's think about that chongqi
was a lesser known actor
um
she-hulk not as well-known imam valani
definitely newcomer
moon knight was oscar isaac
it sounds like it's just a mix yeah i
think it's yeah i think it's i truly
think it's whatever is the best fit for
the role yeah it's all they care about
they don't care about money they just
care about making the best property well
i mean they gave us like even though
chris hemsworth had like that scene he
started trekking at cabin in the woods
like you know nothing big yeah yeah
that was a pretty big catapult
hiddleston was around but that was a big
catapult i think they're good at taking
people
who are at least in that mid tier of
like i know i've seen this guy before
but then like launching them
status
gabe
killian murphy for doctor doom that's
what gabe really wanted us to stop even
though we covered that extensively that
yeah killing murphy would be perfect he
brings competitive a sexual aura to doom
i feel like
killian doctor doomy
i think it's killian i don't think it's
killing um but it would just be silly if
he was silly
but i do i do think it would be uh
there we go
nailed it
uh yeah i think killing could bring a
kind of sexual aura to doom which is
what we need yeah i want sexual
attention obviously sexual doom is what
i want
um sexual attention thank you gabe for
that super chat but yeah
i i i'm getting super hungry you guys
hungry
pretty hungry yeah warren you got food
you got food in the back house all i've
had today is my athletic greens no
longer sponsors
[Laughter]
but i still drink it because it's good
uh hey stingfield pops back do you think
marvel studios hears words of some
projects being too comedy heavy and
maybe want to avert that kind of tone
balancing the tone more
no
i think they kind of just do it per
project is the way they do it i feel
like they might have better sometimes
they do go in
i think that's something marvel could
probably consider better as they move
forward i don't know i think there's
time to do it
but what i think they can do is part of
factoring in their releases is factor in
what their genres are per their releases
because sometimes that tonality shift
it's like
it could be too much of a swing
and from like one type of tone to a
completely different kind of tone
because i was watching for prepping my
video the other day we were do i was
looking at captain america winter
soldier and i was like that was such a
serious movie yeah and i don't know of
any other marvel movie that's like that
serious is there any other mcu movie
that rivals how serious that one is like
even civil war had like hilarious
moments in it
you know like can i get some orange
slices everything like the big
spider-man spider-man yeah yeah so like
uh
like even end game had a lot of fun
infinity awarded you know like that was
so
it's [ __ ] serious and we haven't had
the dark world
but it wasn't yeah there's someone that
helped the funny buddy banter brotherly
banter between the two of them i think
yeah
um so it's a lot of crap but i really
like it has one of my favorite lines in
it
where loki's like or doors like i wish i
could trust you and look alright trust
my rage oh
there's a good line nice and is it
really blind
the mother died you know
um oh yeah we also had someone who just
got a zero edition shirt i gotta shout
them out looky dookie
where'd it go drum roll we need drum
roll sound effect
oh hey that's a great idea bucky barnes
atl our moderator uh it's a good idea to
have koi next time he's on tell him not
to wear a shirt
and then uh and that will go over the
perfectly i mean for the next live
stream but i think you know even for
those she-hulk episodes if he just sits
there shirtless and reacts i think that
could really bridge the gap
oh i'm just looking for something
uh and jeffrey miller feels like warren
is a nice guy in person thank you
i can vouch for that i can vouch for
warren's knife
so let's keep moving
tokyo jetson
which again
tih character do you want brought back i
want the leader in doc
sampson i h
looking it up
the
incredible hulk yes yes which is the
leader into oh doc sampson yeah
that is the biggest clue right there
um that is that uh tim blake nelson yeah
yeah that blue uh yeah um
oh it i didn't hear theories that he
would be coming back into she-hulk
his brain got all big and crazy
don't tell me don't tell me don't look
don't tell me don't
uh yeah i i would love to see
i think doc sampson they did said doc
sampson to be a big villain and he
didn't come into the fold at all yeah
at all
up shut up trying to see your face
[Music]
you know i think bringing back sam
elliott
for thunderbolt ross wouldn't be a bad
call yeah
you never know with marvel and recasting
right it's just yeah yeah they've done
it for people who aren't dead
so i wonder since
um william hurt passed away if they're
gonna just
not recast right right so
i don't know i think samuel would be
perfect i hope they bring him back i
want to see betty ross
is betty ross in the show don't tell me
i'm an editor
i'm an ed harris boy i think ed harris
could do it uh that's that was corey's
top pick okay then i'm not original
anymore i gotta feed the cats guys like
i'm the first person to ever say this
serious business brian o'neill singleton
is back jerry hogarth film
woman
firm there you go thank you jerry
hogarth is from uh jessica yeah freaking
uh carrie anne moss will merge some of
she-hulk's firm allowing for crossover
characters namely luke cage jessica and
danny rand well maybe not
danny this is gonna be so awkward if
they bring it back everybody but him
like it's coming
unless unless unless and this would be a
cool if finn jones like really like took
all this time to get great at fighting
and then came back and like proved
everybody wrong that would be pretty fun
but oh i haven't even thought about
jerry hogarth coming back but she would
be really cool to bring in i thought i
thought carrie anne moss did not get
enough credit for playing that role too
very underrated she was awesome in there
she was like full-on lesbian
yeah not a hollywood friendly lesbian
no she was like so lesbian not a lesbian
you can cut out for china my my point is
is that like you know you get like a
kiss in one of these movies you're like
[ __ ] disney
but then they were otherwise asexual but
now they're not for a second i was like
goddamn guys the [ __ ] jerry hogarth
and jessica jones was like sleeping with
a woman all the time
sure that
if i was in the mcu i would want to just
be uh i want to be ned be a lesbian
field
also screen crush's theory about the tva
being in the quantum realm didn't make
any sense if so then the statue would be
the same in the finale
that's a fair poke
i feel like there's a lot of great stuff
about that theory but that's fair dude
look guys look if if if ryan aries here
i want him to know he can go suck it
yeah
your whole thing's been destroyed now
ryanairy's never been kind
in his life to anyone no he's the most
cocky son of a [ __ ] in the world ryan
airy matter of fact i'm going to text
him right now
that's how cruel he is i have his number
you sure you're a dick ryan do it do it
just out of nowhere wreck his day
oh you know i just had a loss in the
family i don't care your dick carrot
dick ryanairy deserve it
say hi to doug for me a dick
alex c
i'm a winner's place i would love i
would love to have an internship program
here i just put everyone at editing work
and then when they asked to finally get
paid i'd be like
sorry your position is filled you get
college credit
college credit um but yeah i'll tell
it's a screen crush for you to sing
filters alex c there's literally oh
thank you alexey there's literally a
nightmare department of the tva mobius
said so yeah he mentioned vampires
that's another department i would love
to be
happy happily help you burn that down
yeah see bourne knows his stuff
uh guys don't tell ryan area said that
he's going through a really tough time
[Laughter]
oh no ryan's fine uh the i i would love
to see that night i think they're gonna
explore that [ __ ] probably in the next
uh i would hope i hope that wasn't just
like name dropped and then nope that's
it we haven't had a season two yet like
actually air so it hasn't quite hit me
the reality of that there's going to be
a loki season two it hasn't quite hit me
yet until we're watching like oh [ __ ] we
have a season two of loki
right now it's just a thing that i've
heard
but i but i even though there's set
photos an official announcement on the
actual comic con yeah i don't uh
i don't know
erica sinclair
shouts out to you love your work on
stranger things you're doing great you
helped save the day thank you for
subscribing you are now part of our
hellfire club hahaha
ooh josh holloway in the convo for
gambit i'm excited for eternals too i
think they should make it slower
and more meandering and more shots at
magic hour
king thank you tiatric king
oh we're not taking super chats anymore
we're finishing up the last time i
appreciate you wanting to thank you max
just stickers
could you see hulk being a villain one
day oh yeah i would almost
maybe not
hope
because of some of the story arc of
bruce banner but
like an uncontrollable hulk that
for some reason this guy's mean comment
is hidden i need to show it
[Music]
yeah he hides his face because it's a
[ __ ] [ __ ] all right so we have here
dietrich king because he hoping to
villain one day yeah i mean i think
world war hulk
definitely
he's the villain but like he's not wrong
like he was tricked by the illuminati
yeah yeah you know something like that
where he's just full hulk full rage like
i would love to see that because
smart hulk smart hulk was
fun
it was okay
i'd rather have the hulk like the real
hole i want the hulk to come back i
would rather have the real hulk i gotta
admit i enjoy smart hulk right that's
what i'm saying it's like
it's a fine character but i just i want
the hulk back i do i would like hulk to
go back to like
actual
it's like oh he's he's got some real
rage problems you know
right now it's just
mark ruffalo i enjoy it though i i can't
act like i watch it i'm like i'm sick of
this right i don't think that either but
i would like some of that dichotomy
again you know what i mean
all right that could be a cool way to
mix things up for his character make the
rage come back through after so much
time of having control
dakota jones one virus effects on the
instas
matthew
matthew mcconaughey from norman osborne
all right all
[Laughter]
up peter it right be super distracting
but it could also really work yeah
that's not peter i want you to come to
top oscorp tower and i want to show you
a few things i'm gonna take your shirts
off
it's gonna be good
uh
he gives a pretty awesome green goblin i
mean villain defoe's impossible to
replace
william defoe is perfect can spider-man
come out and play
[Laughter]
wake up little spider
wake up
sink field hoops mvp that super cheats
what if marvel made standalone movies
that don't connect and called it phase
zero or added them to the legacy movies
on disney p
ooh i like that phase zero i haven't
actually heard that pitch before have
you do it
no i'm just i think of the phase zero
podcast when i hear that but
phase zero phase yeah
zero edition
zero edition.com what i've been really
hoping that marvel i mean i would love
for them to do that but what i've really
been hoping marvel will do with their
animation department is to adapt graphic
novels directly the way how dc will do
that with some other dc animated movies
like if you you could also give people a
chance to really see a lot of the
changes that are actually made like if
they adapted the infinity saga from the
comics it's so different yeah and i
think that would be so cool to see or
civil war very different you know like
all of them are very different they are
um so yeah i would like that i think i
would really like that'd be cool
[Music]
[Laughter]
so yeah i think that would be awesome um
and now i don't really want to people
have been asking i don't really care to
do reactions to assembled
and thank you rage origins believe it or
not there's a lot we watch that
we don't have a camera pointed our face
for i've seen all of breaking bad and
better call solve without a camera
pointed at me how did you ever survive
the people of your reactions
all right we got one last one here one
last one thank you rage origins on
the stream labs hey taylor
some fan casting for you here we go
andrew
andrew lincoln for reed richards
emily blunt for sue storam
joe kiri for human torch and seth rogen
for the thing killian murphy doctor doom
and a random one
robert sheehan as nightcrawler sheehan
sure i think robert she in his nightclub
was pretty cool
i don't know seth rogen as the thing
would be funny at first but i really do
i don't wanna i'm
i i think too distracting for me there's
there's got to be a torture to the thing
like if you can bring the humor but also
bring the pain to the thing i think
that's uh and i don't
there's a lot that's more required than
just you know a voice to go with it you
got that voice has to have that depth i
think his voice would be distracting oh
no you just be thinking of seth rogen
that's all i would that's all i would
think that's not what he sounds like it
sounds like
yeah that was different
you try again
go again what do you laugh again no
please i've already graced you you don't
know how to yes and do you
what
do you know how to yes and i don't know
what that means
he doesn't know the first rule of it bro
guys give me a location
all right we gotta fix this right now
remember how you're uh
you're hungry and stuff left i am very
hungry yeah yeah we're almost done
we'll get to it but all right we're done
with the super the chats and all that i
think we we are i'm gonna do one last
refresher round but i think that's it
can you bring that to the center of the
screen sure remember this title
guys hayden on the title that's my
heroine pen right here yes
whole time
oh
dude yeah that's nice people say i got a
problem and i say do you want the
channel still be around then let me keep
doing it and the dragon he's chasing is
who would you cast in green hornet
reboot
um
not seth rogen i would i would cast army
hammer
security hornet yes
army hammer and mark
thank you dan truegamer for being here
come on guys we gotta speed around this
speed round it in the next like one i'm
gonna set oh here's what we're gonna do
we're speed rounding the last of the
questions in the chat we're just gonna
do this and then we're gonna say bye i'm
gonna put a two minute timer here once
this goes off we're ending the stream
and saying bye two minutes and go go see
bus chance coy did get buff the link is
on instagram save that since we ran out
of time i'm so sorry i promise next
stream we're gonna play it so we'll save
that link we're gonna do it i promise
you promise promise
uh ben affleck daredevil for secret wars
yes
i say so yeah ben affleck we you cannot
leave this [ __ ] behind who would you
cast as nova
uh ryan gosling i actually like it oh
good call yeah no uh he would eat up the
role harvey hammer i love that
grant gustin could be in the mcu i
wonder who he could be in the mcu i
don't know who that is he's the flash in
the show
no
i said oh gustine
ooh uh did you guys hear the scoop of
toby and andrew and patrick or stewart
returning in secret wars
yeah that sounds like a total
possibility yeah absolutely i don't know
yeah that sounds very likely yeah i
would be shocked if
the uh toby and andrew didn't appear um
let's see here i don't know if anyone
said this but andrew lincoln is read you
guys can't see it
yeah that would be awesome yeah i like
the andrew lincoln's show level tv
hasn't made it to the chat thank you
welcome chill
i'm going to keep this beanie on
uh sean bell thank you sean daniela
you're here for the cat sorry i'm sorry
for laying down the cat you have a
wonderful profile pic rick oh another
wonderful pro topic henry cavill is
hyperion
they are the piano i am the hairball
breeze neil patrick harris
that wouldn't be bad deadpool debut in
thunderbolts might undercut the
thunderbolts a little bit yes agreed
what do you like more as the next saga
comic saga galactus saga eternity saga
the comic saga is just them all having
an existential crisis as they discover
that they are the characters
there are people reading us i think the
galactus saga will be the best you'll
act as saga do you think clint barton's
really retired or is he coming back he's
coming back there's always more arrows
to be unleashed yeah he's got to pick
him up from all over town chris evans is
human torch
that's a good statement they should
probably do that it would be cool if
ultron came back tony stark did save the
world and saved it on that planet 838
yes steve rogers is mr fantastics what
about
chris evans as
um mr rogers
bringing it home
beautiful day in the neighborhood all
right guys thank you so much did you
find you save that link saved it all
right cool save that link guys thank you
for being here thank you for joining us
on this random stream give me a good
excuse to hang out with warren that's
the only way i know how to hang out
that's he needs that what are we gonna
do what do you think we could just hang
out and talk about our feelings and
stuff
dude
you know i'm the last one to be honest
about the way i feel yeah totally
every time you see me crying a reaction
video i'm slicing onions the whole time
why do you think the camera is framed a
certain way some actually to frame out
the engine you got a frame out there you
gotta frame out the onions and then bam
you get a good then people are like whoa
look how sensitive greg actually is he's
not the he's not he's not the tough
tough guy that he he looked at everyone
sees greg and they're like wow he's so
[ __ ] strong and tough and you can
[ __ ] me up that's true yeah but that's
not me man i'm really like a lovable
teddy bear
uh so
red man's land yes scar will join the
mcu someday scar will be back yes i
think scar will be in there yeah
anyway thank you guys for being here
uh warren you're gonna go what are you
gonna eat tonight
food what kind of food you thinking the
ones that you can eat
hmm that's uh that's that's a narrow
answer um and then um keep yelling at me
for answering your questions but i
answer them john uh please what are you
gonna
what are you gonna eat tonight uh i'm
gonna eat the starbucks egg bites i
bought four hours ago
and um
yes i think also there will be other
stories from battle world like in the
comics
and then we will get the main secret
wars arc i feel like secret war is going
to be more expansive i think it's just
going to end right there i think some
people i hopes i hope not no it'd be
kind of weird if you have something that
climatic just kind of over
yeah i think it might be even longer if
they might have divided the secret wars
up into two films
i have that thought like it's kind of i
i i have thought too quick
mine's called secret floors where they
just keep discovering avengers tower has
more and more floors no one knew about
we need that movie hey
good one
all right guys we'll see you soon thanks
for being with us on another weird
stream it's always chaos here we did it
all right
we'll see you
would love to be uh
bye everyone bye kids nice
leave your favorite part in the chat